[Music]
for
now
[Music]
e
your
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh e
[Applause]
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
I
yeah yeah
[Music]
hi
for
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
n
hello
[Music]
can I hi can I
start hi everyone I welcome you to our
session today I know it's early but I
hope you're still ready um I'm really
excited to present the workshop Zer to
dep together with Simon topic is about
how like a new format called zero to dep
how to onboard the next wave of Builders
across the world
World short intro uh short overview I
will talk about what exactly is here to
dep how it how did it started what can
you expect out of this session what is
ethra and then we have a lot of handson
experience with um the graph remix and
Silo zero to depth the name the first
edition started at e San Francisco
2022 it was like a way for um everyone
who is familiar with hackaton it was a
way for for hackers to have a preh
hackaton experience a longer guided
format more Hands-On dedicated workshops
because during the hackaton you usually
have like 30
minutes um technical Workshop where
sponsors are guiding you through how to
build on their product but usually even
even though as a how should I say as a
newb experien hacker this Workshop is a
little bit short um it doesn't really
give enough Insight which is why some
organizations start to have hey let's
have a preone preh hackaton workshop but
you have longer format and each partner
session builds up onto the last one
that's why start zero to dab you start
and the session uh the goal is should
should be that at the end of the session
you as a participant you have built a
dep from the
scratch the format is was like 30
minutes you have a theory followed by
the 30 minutes execution
um after this um after this Edition in
20122 I think it was it took place in
2023 in Paris after before the EC hack
and I'm a haon a and I picked up this
concept and I was like hey when I
founded ethra in 2023 I thought as a way
to onboard especially new hackers why
not having this form as well as in Ghana
it's and this is where the ethra zero to
dep um Edition found its way I think one
of the added value of this format is
also that different Protocols are able
to collaborate betweenin each other for
example we had the graph last year but
and also remix and this year we had um
circles participating I mean the format
is the same but which protocol are
participating can differ and Vary from
City to City another way that also adds
value is as a hacker especially if
you're not really familiar with concept
of hackerone we have many hackers they
just sign up for the zero2 dep and they
felt confident and then after they sign
up to the hackerone because the
hackerone itself can sound intimidating
if you're really familiar with the
concept but if you just come for one day
or two day
workshop gives you a little bit of
insight of what to expect you can also
ask K questions with the protocol it's
more like um a more it's a smaller
setting you can also have a little bit
brainstorming team formation and based
on that we had many people who also
attended the hackaton
itself the formal you can have it in one
day or in two days I mean in Acra last
year we had it one day this year we
decided to have it search on two days we
had a beginner track as well as advanced
track so the format and how the length
Etc is pretty flexible but it just it
should be that the overarching goal
should be that at the end everybody all
the participant have finished um
building their dep within one or two
days are there any questions so
far
okay now I'm happy to talk about a
little bit about
ethra um I find as as you might have
heard I'm a hackaton AIC I love
attending hackaton I've attended I don't
know maybe 15 e go Heaton the past two
years um I realized that usually when I
go to places I'm that don't many women
and also not many African people and I
was thinking okay if people are not able
to come to places like here in Bangkok
or Brussels or San Francisco Etc why not
bring ethereum to Ghana this was the
idea why it started and last year I
found a bunch of people we were like hey
let's create this Hub it has never
happened in West
Africa and yes we were taught like
combine International people with local
people and creating a hub for anyone who
wants to enter um the etherum universe
and then create Amazing
Project um the reason why we doing this
is I think we also want to bring a
little bit a different conversation to
the developer ecosystem globally bring
New Perspectives um and providing
appealing opportunity for companies who
are looking to hire people remotely
because heck is like like I would say a
mini R&D if you always host hackaton in
same region I think usually always have
the same Solutions or projects but if
you host hackaton in different regions
then you also get new insights on
different how people are using your
project because people always build what
is related to their local needs as solve
local problems and I've been a hack I've
hacked in Bogota I've hacked in New York
hacked in bangaluru I've hacked um where
else many different places and obiously
themm hacker I always thought I will not
see something new but each time when I
go to different places I'm exposed to
different way of people are coming out
with solution I think it's very
interesting and if as a company if
you're interested to expand have a more
holistic broader perspective on how
people are using your tool I think you
are not you cannot miss of hosting
hackaton in various regions and being
exposed to different different needs
different um perspective and fresh new
ideas um which is why I think it's a win
for those who want to attend hackaton
but also for companies who want to um
expand a new um region and as we all
know I think African continent
especially West Africa is 75% of the
population is 7 below 35 years it's a
huge youth population and I think the
future of
I don't know maybe the tech up or Tech s
is going to be then it's just right to
have um entry point or way to harness
this huge potential
Market okay
and yes I mean I said I we identified
this opportunity in 202 none of us had
really like become from event
organization background I think we are
just very curious people but believe me
if I knew if we knew what we what it
would expect us I don't know if we would
have done this but we very happy and I
think if we have grown as well and last
it was a huge success which is why we
did again the second edition and popular
demand we will do a third edition as
well next year so if you're interested
to attend a hackaton outside of
the popular path you're highly welcome
to attend um Acra in West Africa
we do annual hack but we also
collaborate with existing communities
for example Pyon react Ghana these are
existing VB
2 and matured communities and based when
we collaborate with them I think we can
leverage on their
synergies um also Swiss Embassy GH also
get notice of us and they also um
supported
us as a way to prepare people or like
bring awareness to what the heckadon is
we did a campus tour we went to
different universities in Ghana where we
did like um not I would not say Road
show but like we did a technical and
non-technical workshop there um the main
target audience were the University
students um last year we did like two
universities this year four and it has
spread the word and that universities
are reaching us to ask that we should
come to their campus um do like ether
Crown campus tour um also and next year
we are planning to do like when they
have like a spring break we do like um
weekl long technical Workshop so the
demand and the need and the interest is
very
high um we were able to participate
with quite um leading eum projects like
the graph sponsored optimism Soo near e
Foundation B GLE haow they all um like
the idea initiative so the demand and
and interest is high because have
started doing more like meetups I mean
usually people start doing meetups and
based on that then doing hack we did
other way around we start the Bold we
just doing a hack first and then now
we're doing more and more meetups to
also have better Community
engagement these are little bit facts
and figures like last year um for first
time Edition we had quite impressive
amount of um people roughly like 100
hackers 18 sub projects five sponsors
10K US dollar we're able to scale it in
a good way and I think for our mission
our goal is to have it slowly but steady
we for us it's more import important
quality um the quantity and we were
happy about the turnout of this year so
the numbers speaks volume we are going
to do a third edition definitely and we
want to build on um these successes and
then who knows the future might be that
some amazing unicorn projects the idea
started at the hackerone it either car
maybe 2025 or
Beyond are there any questions so
far if not then I
think I can pass it on to my
next uh speaker
Rob and he will talk about more the
handsome practical
experience hello Bangkok oh I need the
uh clicker yes it's here I need not to
electrocute myself if I spell the T
um the next slide is not
that the next slide is who I thought
there was another next slide
there so uh I'm at I work at remix it's
a online IDE and uh if you want to do a
uh zero toap workshop and want to join
our community of zero toap Workshop uh
organizers take that telegram group and
we can uh support you give you some
ideas about how we organize the projects
we've done before and uh maybe even send
you some SEO eth for all your hackers or
hook you up with other projects or uh
anyway so there's that and the next one
is uh onto remix so just so I get a
sense of uh who's here everyone knows
what a smart contract is or
no oh good okay and and of the people
that know what a smart contract is has
anyone ever deployed
one ah okay and has anyone used remix
before
well it's going to be a review for the
use but anyway here we go so uh we're g
to basically like first you when you
start up remix well first you got to
know the URL to start up remix otherwise
you're
sunk and then um just so you know a
little bit of the uh layout of remix
like there's
a this part over here there's the icon
panels and that's where you switch out
the plugins which are over
here here's a console here's a terminal
uh and there's the Home tab and when you
start writing code the codee's going to
appear in the Home tab in a tab in the
Home tab something like
that um so you got to get some templates
it's an easy way to start if you just
want to start looking at what some code
looks
like and uh yeah maybe that's better um
and so to get the code you oh I can look
over
here
uh you go to the hamburger menu actually
that's another question I had because I
do devr I'm writing all these docs does
everyone know what a hamburger menu
is okay okay so you click the hamburger
menu and then um anyway that's what the
um the file explorer looks like and then
you click the hamburger menu and if you
do that then you can get this pull down
menu and then you can select uh create
using template
so it's creating a workspace so in remix
files are in workspaces and then you can
select the workspace the template you
want those are that's a erc2 one if we
were going to be so typically in know a
zero to DAP Workshop there's someone
like me that gets up and Rambles away
and then you kind of catch what you
catch and then you go and you do some of
your own uh do some uh work on it like
you'd use a tool I give you a recipe to
follow and then you could uh play with
it on your own and then the next speaker
comes up and builds on it and
so you know like um in Simon's one when
he talks about the graph you'd be using
a erc20 project so we would get one in
remix and then deploy it uh but now
we're just going to I just going to give
you a quick run through of remix and
then I'll show you on the tool and I'll
fumble around on the tool and we'll see
if it works uh so then you can also
clone GitHub repos into
remix uh you can what else you can do
yeah so it's simple to get a GitHub repo
you can also grab verified contracts on
ether scan and bring them into remix you
can go to the open Zeppelin Wizard and
open in remix button uh and you can also
go to um you can write your own
code just like click that icon there in
the top of the file explorer underneath
the workspace pull down
menu and in remix it's important to know
like it's an online IDE so there's no
setup but also it means that the files
are stored in browser storage so you
have to know that and uh it can you know
if browser storage gets corrupted then
you lose your your work so either you
got to push it to a repo if you want to
save it you could download it to your
computer
or yeah or or you can work with with
remix D which is a little script that
runs locally that allows you to share a
folder on your hard drive with the
browser and also we have remix desktop
in beta right now so you can work with
remix
offline um and just so also like in
remix there's a lot of plugins for lots
of additional functionality and you go
to the plug-in manager at the bottom
there and so you kind of you click that
and you choose the one you want to
activate and then it will activate and
the icon will appear on the left column
there uh so you get the file you want
and you want to compile it oh look
another member of the remix team coming
in the
door uh so you compile
the the you compile the active file from
the active tab in the main panel and you
click the compile
button and um what's that oh yeah there
are multiple ways to compile you can you
know click the uh play button you can
click compile you can go to the uh uh
the uh what you call it solidity
compiler and click it there or you can
do just controls to compile and then you
can after it's compiled then you can
grab the ABI which is important for
making your
daps and then you
deploy and uh deploy panel is the run a
deploy panel is a little U dense but
it's important to get to know it you
choose the environment that means like
what chain you're going to deploy to
local chain or a chain using a browser
wallet to connect to a a public chain uh
and then you can add value to your
transactions uh which is
uh over here uh and then you can select
which account you want to use and in the
remix VM which is the local chain inside
the browser in remix there gives you 10
10 accounts with 10 with a 100 ether
each um
and you can also deploy to different
environments you can deploy it to local
chains you can deploy it using metamask
which is using or whatever browser
wallet you want using injected provider
and then there's other ones we check the
bottom one which says customize this
list and then you can go to another Tab
and so anyway uh then you hit click
deploy after you've got the file
compiled and then uh it appears Below in
this deployed contract section
and you get this little green uh thing
when the uh button there uh and if you
want to debug it you can launch a
debugger section by clicking on the
debugger tab in the
terminal uh so once you open up the uh
deployed contract in the deploy and run
you get this um kind of Pop down menu or
this accordion and then orange buttons
are for pay are for uh where you're
saving to the the blockchain blue
buttons are just read functions and red
ones where you can are payable
functions and uh then you can open those
each one of those up further and if
they're multiple inputs you can dial
that thing down and then you can put the
inputs in individually and it tells you
what the input type should
be and then you can copy the address
there and now you can even pin the
address so that next time you come back
to remix
you can uh get that easily uh then the
other part is uh is contract
verification is very important and uh so
people can read your source code and to
do that you got to open up the contract
verification plug-in down in the plug-in
manager and then it comes up and then uh
you can deploy you can verify on
multiple um verification services
and then the this verification plugin
has multiple tabs and so you can verify
on one if you using one of the services
like ether scan uh you got to put in
your API API key so then you go over to
the settings tab and put that in and
then come back to the verify Tab and
verify the contract on this the chain
that you deployed it
to uh and then there's also um learning
things in remix because when you're
learning got
questions so you can ask remix AI so
there's a bunch of ways remix works you
can there's code explanations like
explain a contract or block a code you
can get coding assistance like when
you're when you're um coding you can say
like write a function that counts to 50
or whatever you want and then um you can
get coding uh completion while you
type so in the robot icon up there it'll
explain that contract I'm kind of
whipping through it so I can just show
you quickly in remix uh when I get to
that um so anyway uh that will explain
the contract and it'll right now it'll
appear in a new uh uh AI assistant panel
right now this is like the previous
version so it's appearing in the
terminal um and then you can uh get AI
to help you with compiler
errors so you just click that AI button
and then it'll give you the answer in
the uh AI assistant terminal I mean uh
panel right now it's in the terminal
but so uh you can get explanations
initiated from that robot icon but also
when you uh click on some
code and um what you got here oh yeah so
you can explain this code you can expl
explain this function
and then you can also get coding
assistance on request but to do that you
need to turn on the switch there a lot
of little things hidden around remix so
you turn on the switch and then you can
inside a inside a contract with the
three slashes you can say like WR
whatever you
want what's that one say uh yeah and
then um
and when you're uh each time you ask it
to do this it will give you a different
answer so if you don't like the answer
it gave you then ask
again and then there's code completion
uh and sometimes um that could get
annoying if you don't like it then you
can turn that off by switching that top
thing the top switcher and then there
learne tutorials which are tutorials
inside a remix um just a wanted to put
this little note here if this little uh
icon up there if you click that then the
plugin will bounce over to the right
side of the panel so then that means
that you can um you can be getting the
instructions on one side and doing the
work on the other and uh should be super
fun uh then we have this remix guide
which you can either get to from the uh
plug-in manager or from the Home
tab and they get a bunch of
videos and there are a bunch of lowl
solidity videos which are kind of
complicated there's some just intro to
remix videos there's some intro to
solidity
videos knock yourselves
out and then you could ask
somebody and a good way to ask somebody
who especially is not next to you is to
send them a
gist uh so you can just do that pretty
easily just from the uh file explorer
and right click you get this popup
menu and uh you get a
gist and your gist is ready okay so now
I'm going to show you how to deploy a
contract in
remix I think I can do it like
this no oh did I yeah look at that okay
so here we got
remix and you can see it's in uh there
are different themes in remix so you
could go to the settings tab and switch
that if you want uh and uh and this one
is set up with the erc20 contract but
here I'll make a new one uh using a
template and then we're going over here
and then we're
gonna uh set erc20 burnable
minable we're going to create
it and it's going to
load and then uh here look so then uh it
loaded all the
dependencies so just to note like to do
the dependencies with the import
statements if it's uh importing
something that's a mpm package you just
do it like that it'll remix will grab it
from unpackage and then uh you got that
here I'm going to compile this using
this little
button here look it compiled but we're
going in the solidity compiler you go
here if you want to switch your solidity
version and if you're loading some old
contracts you probably need to change
your solidity version
and so that's loaded uh yeah and here's
the uh ABI if you want to grab
that here and then we're going to deploy
to the local VM here I'm going to grab
my my contract CU I'm going to Mint it
to
myself put it in here here but I'll dial
this
down a
chunk
transact so um you can see that and then
um so add address is when you're uh want
to access an already deployed contract
so if you just have the chain the right
chain connected uh then you can and you
have the um ABI then you can uh pull in
a contract or the source code you can
pull in a contract
uh uh from that's already
deployed and uh so uh so yeah so so like
it's interesting here there's like a
bazillion uh functions here okay so now
we're going to deploy to a public
net and we're going to do that with
uh what's going on here
uh oh got to customize this
list so we enabled the injected
provider and then um we're g
to and we're connected to
sepolia but if we wanted to connect to
some other chain we click here and we go
to chain
list and chain list you just put in the
the chain if you want to deploy like to
uh scroll soolo you put scroll in here
scroll well you get the idea anyway uh
you can get there and if you click the
one that you select it'll configure the
browser wallet and then you don't have
to put any uh RPC stuff it just does it
automatically and what else uh yeah okay
so it's uh we're connected there we're
going to deploy
here now it's going to want
approval and I'm going to give it
approval and you have to
wait cuz it's pending and maybe when the
Internet is slow it takes a little
while oh did it happen I think it
did yeah so now we can see uh the
um the functions from this
deployment uh just also note that um
here's the evm version and you can
select the evm
version back here in the advanced
settings but uh anyway so we've deployed
it here and just uh quickly just so you
have this little uh secret thing here is
uh you can quickly make a Dap here you
click
that and uh you can quickly just deploy
this to this stap on surge you can make
a free account you can uh put in your uh
name of the DAP some instructions you
can there's like a million um functions
and maybe like you don't want to show
them to somebody you just want to show
like uh a couple of functions so you
just select the ones you want you can um
get rid of that you can move this one
over
here then you put in like username and
password and then you you'll when you
hit deploy you'll have a URL outside a
remix that you could just pass to
someone and then they can check out your
functions and if it's a verified
contract then uh you can open up the
code someone can open up the code back
in
remix you got a
question it's
better
sure um so I just deployed this here
onto
sapoia and then I'm going to go to the
plug-in
[Music]
manager and go down to uh contract I'm
going to
search contract
verification and um so you can um we're
going to select uh
sapoia and it's this contract
and
um this is asking if it's a proxy
contract but this one
isn't and uh ether scan is not enabled
here because you need to put in the um
what ah don't worry about
it I mean if you wanted to do it you
could just uh you go to the settings tab
over here but it's not going to it's not
that important I mean you could do it or
not or anyway so
um uh we're verifying
it oh valid contract address oh I see
okay maybe this wasn't
the I'm going to put it here
that was not a valid contract
address wow that's
tricky okay uh uh copy the address oh I
see what happened okay so anyway uh go
back to contract
verification let me take this me grab it
all delete it and paste
it now we'll
try will it work
oh oh you're
right the contract I wanted to verify uh
my
token you're
good Kajun oh valid contract address
didn't like it
okay is this the API key again
nope
okay we got the verification in the
verification receipt
section it's not going to be on ether
scan it because we didn't put the API
key in but it's on block Scout and uh
sourcify but if we put the API key in
it'll be on on um uh ether SC
can so we have four different
verification services and also sourcify
is interesting because uh if you just
deploy the if you publish the source
code on ipfs and you deploy it will
it'll find the um source code on ipfs
and it will it goes through all deployed
contracts on most on a lot of chains so
you don't even need to do anything but
if you don't uh publish the uh sour code
then it's not going to give you a full
match I mean it's not going to work on
sourcify
um any other
questions um yeah there's lots more and
you can check the remix docs here
there's a kind of like a little trick
here if you want to go just go right to
the docs you go here and then you can go
to the
documentation that little thing this
little fold up thing at the top and um
uh um what
else my tokens
here uh okay anyway I think that's
uh good enough unless anyone else has
any
questions
yeah often that's because there's uh
kind of error in the code if oh oh the
other thing is um after you after you um
compile uh like
um not doing it here but you often see
the um the gas
fees on each line on the contract
line anyway um but
um there there could be the or or you
can also go to the um gas section to um
let's see over
here and um up the gas you have to click
custom to up the
gas but it's of an indication of
something else going
on um here and I'll just show you a uh
quick um we'll make a little compiler
error here and we compile
it and um go back up here we see the
error we go over here and we go to remix
Ai and we
see uh we'll get the answer over
here it's quite a thorough
answer so that's what I
got
Simon I pass the torch
yes curs is it similar to curser it's
totally different a totally it's totally
different code
base oh the AI model it's a code llama
yeah cool
thank
you
rob hi
um my name is
Simon do you still hear me yes okay cool
uh yes so um thank you Rob so the idea
of zero to dep as I said like it's kind
of building up so um foundational
usually is to learn about smart
contracts and uh yeah when you go into
adapt development but uh then we can
have building blocks uh going on top
like um I'm working on the graph
protocol so the building block that I
think is the next is um using the graph
to index that data from the blockchain
so um we can quickly run that uh thank
you rob
again uh through some slides um that
explains like how to access it but I
want to emphasize here like in the zero
to depth context like have having the
graph is one idea it could be other uh
other things that get data into your
front end or other protocols that you
can can uh build on top like we had zero
to deps um setups were like L after
after the graph maybe T tenderly came to
present or we had like polygon that
showed how it works on their chain um
may we also worked with wallets and so
on so forth so like that's basically
open the idea is just like that we run
through in one course and that each each
session Builds on top of each other so
that people that really take the time
sit in um that they yeah and end up with
something that is working and also to
Showcase how nicely actually all these
different protocols and projects play
together because um uh yeah we're kind
of from the same chain and have this
interoperability the the Lego blocks um
I think it's very nice anyways um so as
I said like my name is Simon uh I do
theop experience at ATO it's one of the
C that's working on the graph
and quickly uh who knows what the graph
does okay yeah I I can run through the
slides like basically it's about
accessing blockchain data um so when we
think about data on the blockchain when
we send a transaction we always pay gas
uh to incentivize the validators to
bring that transaction into the chain uh
so like that's that's why people run
validators because they can get part of
that gas or actually they get Block
rward Parts but you know what I'm
talking about but like when you want to
um read data from the blockchain I mean
there is a interface called Json RPC
that helps to get data directly out
of of of of the of the blockchain node
but it is not an optimized way of
getting data out it's a very low level
interface to get data um so that results
like in code like this um that's
actually a project that I that ask me at
some point like hey we have problems in
our front end it's very very slow what
can we do and when you look through it
if you understand JavaScript do you
understand JavaScript and
typescript good uh yeah then you see
there all these await statements and all
these await statements they they it's
kind of like they the frontend code
works with Chason RPC endpoint and they
wait until the results come and let's
say and this is just like in showing
nfts and if the person has 10 nfts that
he can easily take like a second or two
to load and I mean we are used like if
if if you are uh using uh web 3 or the
centralized applications on everyday
basis kind of like know it takes longer
always like very
long um but like like the next you know
the next wave of people that comes in
they will probably like after a second
say like ah this page probably doesn't
work um so we need to work on this so
one of the things that people started to
do is um building their centralized
index kind of like setting up servers
and server uh in their server Farms
whatever or connecting to service
providers that do it for them or
whatever um and build and build that
thing and it's okay I mean it works but
on the other hand I like a lot of the
properties that we were looking for if
they Center Technologies are a little
bit circumvented like that I mean if
that server goes down basically the
application is unusable anymore uh it's
also a the single point of censorship
like if there's any any problems um then
it can can go down but there's also
often a vendor lock in um that uh
especially service providers that
provide such a service they they might
or might not just change the service
change the API change the pricing or
whatever and if you build an application
on top of something like that uh yeah
that can break
so that's basically a little bit where
the graph if subgraphs sit um so having
like a decentralized network of indexes
that basically care about that problem
um they run graph nodes which is a fully
open- Source MIT stack that you can also
run on your own um data center or local
machine to for development but um it is
in in a decentralized network it's there
and it's running so you don't need to
care if you don't want to um there are
over 9,000 subgraphs uh published so
basically every big protocol has a
subgraph uh on on the graph Network um
so that's pretty cool so it's it's it's
a it's easy way to have like data
accessible and then we end up with with
this Paradigm like that the UI sends the
transactions directly to the blockchain
Via Jason RPC it's also then the Jason
RPC works pretty well and then the
subgraph basically watches those Chase
watches those contracts see what's going
on right in the store and then the UI
can read from the
subgraph that's a thing uh the the graph
is as I said it's a decentralized
network it consists out of uh 110 index
across the world the big number of
delegators cators not so important as a
developer but actually also subcraft
it's almost like a 10K subcraft right
now so like uh if you like if you
develop your new contracts usually you
write a new subcraft but if you're
interested in just getting data out of
what's going on then there might be
radius UPG graph that uh gives you that
data but in this zero to dep what we do
is like we build a new uh
contract uh yeah you can think of
subgraphs as something like this there's
this this like huge uh around things of
of data on the blockchain and it's
unordered and and we want to bring it in
order and so that's where subgraphs come
in or when we go through to the um
example from before like this this uh
ugly J JavaScript query that we saw or
JavaScript code we can have a graphql
but we s just like one transaction and
to the to a graph node or an indexer and
then uh we have the the results and it
usually takes I think average response
time current is 150 milliseconds so
that's uh as Snappy as we would like to
have our applications
be yes and the subgraphs are
customizable apis so it's code so
they're written in code it's the code is
called assembly script it's similar to
typescript it has some quirks but uh
usually it's it's easy learnable and um
that whole technology by itself is like
as I said it's it's an industry standard
it's open source and but while writing
subgraphs uh it's also then able to
publish it to that registry the graph
Explorer and so it's it's a little bit
of a market plate of data sets or a
collaborative registry of data sets that
have blockchain data and if you write a
new contract you can bring your uh
subgraph also to that registry um yes so
as I said like there's the graph
Explorer to explore subgraphs but we
mainly look at uh the gra.com
studio
um yes so
like like the the in the workshop of Rob
who was actually following and also
deployed an esc20
token right now what's that someone
one two
nice two and a half okay
so zero to death workshops usually take
uh a day or two and today we do it in an
hour or one hour and a half so usually
we are there and say like okay now you
you follow here and click here and you
deploy and stuff and then we have a uh
like mentors around that help people
people to sit down when they're blocked
uh it's like unfortunately we cannot do
it here so we run through the theory and
some people might be able to follow some
people not um but yeah there will be the
heon on the weekend and I will be there
and so you can just try to do it there
but I'll show it how it
goes so when I also share the slides in
the telegram group so because I also
made screenshots but I tried to just do
the the live demo
here
so when we go to the gra.com
SL
studio uh you can sign a
message to login oh yeah that's my test
subgraph but but usually there is um
here is a button to to create a new one
if there isn't any but I can create one
I can give it a name um live
Devcon actually the best practice is to
give it a proper
name with spaces and capital letters and
that stuff and then here you will see it
it created that
Slug and then when we have that subgraph
in the subgraph studio uh there is
basically the instructions here on the
right that you could just follow in
order to get started with with a
subgraph and it's actually it's pretty
easy so I go in my terminal
here may need to make it a little bit
bigger so that's the first command I run
I run this so I'm getting the latest
graph CLI installed on my local machine
scen
um in the meantime I try
to verify that token
here for
here yeah I want to from the owner
actually here ah no okay right
thank
you it's good to have experts in the
room like that's that always
helps okay so I can go over to get the
contract address and then the deployer
address was
probably I can get the owner here
nice okay if so you had that question
right about how to verify an ether scan
so we did it so you need to have an API
key add it add it to to remix and then
it should work like the quirks are you
need to find the contract address where
you deployed it when you do it the first
time um I mean I I I probably spent an
hour once to find it again uh and you
need to know the deployment arguments
that that you gave uh one of the
workarounds for me is like I started to
write contracts without deployment
arguments and at all because it's always
it's just a hassle to verify them um but
yeah everybody finds its own ways but
now now what what's important for
starting to write the sub graph what I
wanted to say is like uh you need to
have uh a verified contract on ether
scan at the moment like we're working on
integrating especially with sourcify
since this is this canonical open uh
code uh source code registry but
unfortunately as the state is right now
uh EOS scan has the most verified
contracts and so this uh is around but
having said that I think now we should
have the latest um graph CI installed
that looks good and then we basically
just follow the steps here so we do
graph in it
uh live
Devcon and that that dialogue is it
visible that dialogue um
yeah kind of forces forces us to go
through like uh some questions so the
first is the protocol so the graph
also supports other blockchains than
ethereum but we don't care it's Defcon
only ethereum is
important uh then like the subcraft log
is um so ethereum here means evm
compatible actually so the subgraphs log
we we we we take it from here see I said
like there's this logy thing going on so
we it's lowercase and dashes for
spaces um but um it's all automatically
then we can get a directory I usually
just go with the one that's there and
then we can select the chain see and
it's like most um evm compatible chains
are
around we go
Foria here we go and now we need to have
the contract address
again and since we have it
here can get it over and now as you see
it fetches the ABI it fetches the star
block it even fetches the contract name
directly from EOS scan so we don't need
to do much the star plock also is
here my token and then the last question
is like index contract events as
entities
which scaffolds out the whole subgraph
like database schema uh mapping code and
everything that just indexes all the
events in my opinion this is already
um come
on maybe because of the
I
know it's probably because of the
pointer
interesting um where was I so yeah so we
have it scaffolded out yeah now actually
I can show you quickly how that looks
like while it's installing in the
background so a subgraph basically is
just like simple uh nojz project you see
there's a package Chason file there is a
yeah it's a package Chason file with
some commands like there's some
dependencies um but then like what I do
when I look at the subr I look at the
subgraph yaml this is what everything
keeps everything together so it says uh
what we said before um like where is the
like which contract which contract
address is it uh where was that contract
deployed so we don't need to look at
blocks that are older than the
deployment block um on which which
network are we which uh like blockchain
thing do we have is e ethereum or
something else um and more like there
there's a whole document about what we
all have here but like here I said these
are the event handlers and for the
contracts for the esc20 contracts mostly
important is the transfer event so with
the transfer event we can basically
reconstruct everything like because in
the transfer events we see the mints
that they go from address zero to some
address and then with with um with an
amount and then when when tokens are
sent around so that's basically it but
the orders are here depending on the
contract that you write uh that's all
scaffolded out then there is a dat
database schema so the schema grq think
about just a database schema for
everybody that knows about the database
schemas um just table
definitions um with uh yeah just table
definitions where where event stuff is
stored and again for the transfer we see
there is an ID there's a from it's
encoded in bytes which is an address a
two encoded in bytes again the value
like how much tokens changed hands and
then the block number when it happened
the uh the block time stamp when it
happened and the transaction has so
these basic building blocks already
would would help me to write the front
and to just uh display all the
transactions that happened on that token
uh also some code is autogenerated here
you see it's in it's in typescript for
those that are able to R type script or
JavaScript it's pretty simple so this is
a good starting point I don't even touch
any of that code it's just a boiler
plate but I want to to quickly show you
how that's
organized uh so that later on you can uh
go crazy and do your own stuff if you
want because we ran this thing so then
we just go further with copy pasting
out uh the authentication please don't
uh steal my AP key here I know the
session is recorded So I mean need to
change later we did already go into the
directory so we don't need to do this
then there is this graph Coden and graph
build there's some autogenerated code
out of the schema and of the manifest
like that yl file that we looked there's
some helper code created
and uh and then like the whole thing in
the end is compiled down into web
assembly the good thing about web
assembly is that it gives us a very uh
robust sandbox so that the indexes don't
need to be afraid of running your
subgraph code uh because like some smart
engineer tried to hack some stuff in so
the assembly script is really secure uh
uh samp
boox and then I can just simply run
graph deploy life Devcon that's
it I give a version number so I go with
the
default and that's it and then I see
here in the UI it starts in the
background like uh to sync um we did not
do any transactions
yet so we don't see anything see like
when you go on ether scam and you look
at transactions it's basically only
deployed so it would be a little bit
more interesting if you have any
transactions
right
um so we can go
here was it yeah it's minable right yeah
you you create interal
so how do we do that so let's we mint
ourselves some
tokens yeah
some uh and what happens if I mint
oh ah where do I see the the problem
let's see if we just send
it
do no
unauthorized
account no no I know I
we so the owner is Set uh the owner is
set to another account
probably the in probably said the owner
to the injected
account uh the this one yeah
5B um do we have do we have the private
key of that account is it the normal one
from that also scaffold def uses
that
no it's not I have
them okay
uh how much time do we have left I need
two minutes and then I can fix it or
five
okay let's s it
again
for for
okay I redeployed the contract and now
it's pretty simple I just need to change
the address here in the subgraph yaml so
that it points to the to the to the new
contract and then I can
redeploy my
subgraph go a version
up actually I would not even have to
verify it like this because the subgraph
it just needs to have the ABI of the
token here and that the ABI didn't
change so if you have the ABI and to
contract address then we can we can spin
up the subgraph so anyways so now we
have that um thing deployed
here now we have two
entities all
right um but we can look for transfers
from two value so let's look for
transfers so now we don't have any
transfers as you see I can go into the
playground and then here on the right I
can open and close this graphic explorer
that helps to uh discover the
schema um but here now in remix I can
actually send transactions so this is
the new contract so now try again to
Mint
myself some
tokens now it's
working nice
boom and we see the tokens here woo it
worked always these live demos makes me
sweaty
[Applause]
hands okay
um yeah I'll share these slides later on
in the telegram group that we have if
you didn't join the telegram group yet
I'll get the QR code up again wow so
many slides today
sorry so this is the QR code I will
share the slides in the telegram group
um what I also have shared in the
telegram group is uh Google
Sheets um so what we did what we do
usually at this work or like one way to
to run the workshops if if with particip
participants in the room is uh to really
walk with them through the steps until
they each deployed their own erc20 token
on seoa so we have like a shared or like
whatever test net you want to work with
and so everybody has that that token and
then we ask them to add their eoa or the
address that they use to deploy the
token and the contract address into that
Google sheet right and then we have a
Google sheet of all the participants
that have uh the the contract deployed
and then we tell we can tell them to
send now around tokens to each others
and that works right and then each has
the the subcraft that tracks its token
and then we can see like uh yeah we can
we can see that the shared state that we
work on so I added an example uh Google
Sheets there if you want you can um also
do that to today or later or I don't
know next week or whatever and ping me
and then we can maybe uh do that but
that's that's what we do in a live setup
um also at the telegram group but I will
also share the slides later on so you
can um build on top of the slides but I
think the last slide of me
is yeah the screenshots of
everything
um but yeah actually there is also like
uh then the next step usually is now we
have a smart contract we have now
subgraph is is building a whole front
end or a whole UI whole application and
for that we partnered up with scaffold
Le scaffold Le they have a bunch of
different um set sessions here workshops
I think one runs right now in parallel I
really uh can yeah can suggest to check
them out it's very very cool project but
what's important from from from here is
that there is a plugin to to scaffold
out the scaffold e project with a
subgraph already included so that makes
it very easy and then it's very well
integrated uh it's just this one command
like basically the normal command plus-
e and then subgraph uh we which includes
that and they also work on on other
plugins so like there's a a group of
plugins or or if you're working for a
protocol that wants to be integrated
with scaffold leave like you can also
reach out to them and integrate your
stuff too um yeah check it out um I
think that's it from my
side if there are any questions we can
also do questions
let's see if someone posted a question
is question
QR I know okay yes please
elaborate like web tr. GS to interact
with the deploy smart contract now at
this level you're introducing the
subgraph so at which level can we place
subgraph what is the uh what it is
really use for used for I like to to
really understand why we need it uh in
the process of developing is it for
performance or yes Al so
yeah I mean uh the presentation is not
that much about like uh showing what the
graph is more about the SC the zero to
that but I can go into it quickly so so
yes it is possible for a UI to directly
get data out from the blockchain with
Json RPC that's possible and that's also
so so usually what people learn first
when they go when you go to when you
look at scold leave uh without the
subcraft plugin that's what what you end
up but as I said like here in this
problem statement um getting data out
via Json RPC at scale gets problematic
pretty quickly um you yeah in in so you
end up with code like this so you you
you send a lot of asynchronous queries
to the to the Chas RPC end point trying
to get that data out maybe you get it
into into your front end then you try to
Crunch it together in the front end and
you end up with like slow and
complicated code um and then the first
step is usually that you think about
like oh maybe I should have my own
server and then have your own database
and then you store then you run all that
stuff and do stuff in your database on
your server that you run somewhere on
AWS or whatsoever but then you are again
basically locked into that system that
you build up on um where you where you
host your servers or if you're on awx
maybe Jeff Jeff Bezos wants to raise
prices or whatever or for whatever Reon
for whatever reason they do some IP
blocking or you know but all that stuff
that we see and but with with subgraphs
or like there other indexing
Technologies like the graph uh there is
a possibility of spilling on top of
stand of Industry standards that um help
you that to to have that data available
for your front end does it answer the
question okay thank you please another
one
yes uh yes once I deploy the soft the
subgraph okay uh is there a possibility
to know or to to query the event that
occur before the deployment of this
subgraph okay which events are you
particularly interested
in no I just want to understand and I
mean like if you want to for example I
can imagine that you're interested in
other contract events right yes yes then
you
can
uh it's basically go to this subgraph
yaml and then you basically copy paste
the whole data sources
here create a new one and then you
change that contract address that start
block then you basically tell the
subgraph hey there is another contract
that I'm interested in maybe you want to
look at this um events too okay thank
you
other questions there is one in the
front it's a simple question what is the
difference between subgraph and graph
node node graph when we deploy a
subgraph is there a graph node deployed
behind yes so the graph node is
um uh as I said like it's a fully open
source uh software technology written in
Rust
that runs usually alongside a archive
node of ethereum and the subgraph is a
piece of code you can think of that's
compiled into web assembly and then
deploy it to a graph node and the graph
node runs the subgraph and while running
the subgraph it's basically a set of
instructions to tell the graph node what
data to get out of the blockchain and
how to store it in a database and how to
give access via graphql to other people
so the graph node is basically the run
the execution environment for the
subgraphs thank
you wait wait you you need the
microphone for the
recording so how how does the pricing or
the fees work for subgraph do you pay um
with some transaction fees every time
you make a read
call like the you can run the graph note
by yourself as I say it's a it's open
source but if you using the graph
Network there is a paper
query oh okay got it but like it's
basically you you you put money into
into the system and then
it deducts for you when does U graphs
start to make sense like what scale of
data are we talking
about it
depends I know I personally like to
start with the subcraft immediately it
also helps to to write the smart
contracts a little bit more lean because
like um in my experience a lot of
subcraft uh smart contract developers
they end up writing
functions that that you only need them
for data for data
access um but you can skip those make
your sub smart contracts a bit more lean
and more focused and then and and
already start with a with indexing
solution from the from day one um but it
also depends a little bit on on your
team I mean I'm as I'm more of a full
stack or front developer I was often
looped into teams when that when you
have like dedicated smart contract
developers there are solidity people and
when you talk to them about JavaScript
then uh they become
angry and uh and then it's kind of like
that setup right and then for me like
then subgraphs are very useful because
it's basically a a line of defense
because I can build a subgraph in
between the contract and my front end
and whenever they whatever they do on
their contract it doesn't necessarily
immediately influence my front end work
so it also helps with
this um but yeah I would say like maybe
if you really a beginner like if if it's
your first uh smart contract then you
might not want to already go into into
the graph although or other Technologies
in general although uh with that steps
that I just showed it's also not that
hard makes sense and on the flip side if
um let's say you are a pretty pretty old
project you have large amount of data on
blockchain already and you want to
introduce a subgraph uh how complex that
is complex or simple that is sorry can
you repeat the question um uh on a flip
side let's say if you're an older
project you have large amounts of data
already on the blockchain yes um and
it's really slow and you decide to start
using subgraph how difficult or easy it
is to integrate subgraph in your
project yeah then that's the same I mean
like what I what I just showed like just
going through that initialization steps
just having your uh events index is
already a a big plus actually um it's
already speeding up stuff and then and
from there you can iterate upon so I
think it's basically no Nob brainer I
mean yeah there is some there is it's
it's a it's some learning curve to learn
the technology but yeah but integrating
is fairly straightforward okay yeah that
was that was very often like the
actually the developer Journey was like
oh they come they come and want to keep
their systems lean which I understand
usually I also try to have as little
dependencies as possible to start a
project but at some point you run into
the scale issues and then they come
uh but yeah they could also avoid it and
have it from the beginning about them
makes sense thank
you other
questions all right thank you so much
thank you rob for the invitation thank
you abna thank you for coming thank
you okay okay this point we going for a
break now
[Music]
next
one probably not around maybe January or
February March
[Music]
per
yeah let's let's make a photo for CH so
he knows that met
you are okay right now
[Music]
wa
I know I know
[Music]
a
you a
[Music]
all do
see
[Music]
h
d
[Music]
your
h
[Music]
m the
[Applause]
[Music]
I
e
[Music]
e e
all
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hello everyone uh my name is
Fernando he is my colleague Diego uh we
are from E arm um we are trying to show
today how to uh build I think thing that
we call Super node device Hardware this
is a hardware demonstration and I
encourage you to come closer if you want
to see how we are going to build the the
machine and we are going to uh do
everything in life here we hope this is
going to work because it's a live demo
and always is it's hard to to to tell
but uh if you want to see the the the
ARM device and all the things that you
need to create your own not at home uh I
encourage you to go closer in order to
to see all the the things that we are
going to do outside the the camera here
in in our this is small
lab
uh uh where
the help
uh here it's
here so this is this are not the best uh
conditions uh especially Network
conditions because well we are in a
close environment we're going to do is
uh to launch a script that uh is the grd
that installs
everything uh so you can uh make an idea
of what's going on
there it's
cool okay
uh this is really what what we do we
help users to run ethereum nodes in low
power devices uh like this one this is a
rock 5B but uh there are also uh the
orange pi5 plus and the nano6 there are
very similar devices uh uh they uh they
have an AR arm 64 core and um 16 gab of
RAM and our our vision of of with noes
uh these are the the uh features of of
these devices low power consumption
affordable uh these devices are less
than $200 um great for lightweight nodes
and testing environments uh uh and
growing support and commun resources we
have a Discord channel uh we have a
extensive uh documentation page where
you can uh see uh pretty much everything
what you need to to fire up a note and
if you don't know how or you have uh
some question you can also come to to
our Discord Channel and we we can help
you
there so a super note is basically um
a ler one note a ler one client and a
ler uh two client running along in the
same device uh so usually you uh you uh
run them separately but uh what we
wanted to do here is uh to demonstrate
that how powerful these devices are and
the only thing uh that you need uh
especially for for this uh setup is uh a
device with 32 gabt of RAM
so uh pretty much the the the
um the operation is the same you you
need to start uh uh two system Dev two
system services for the L1 client and
two system service for the L2 client and
once you do that uh you have a supern
running uh an L1 client running and then
L2 run
yeah as you know um in the in the last
years uh ethereum it's been uh
struggling with scalability and and L2
nodes are very important and uh we
wanted to give users the ability to run
these kinds of nodes because uh we think
that uh as well as you can verify the
chain with the L1 nodes it's important
that you can interact directly with with
L2 notes as
well so so the boards as I was saying um
these are the the devices that we
support uh orange pip orange P5 um is a
little discontinued because it doesn't
have uh a good this support but uh it
still works and for the super nodes you
need uh 32 GB of RAM that's the only
difference with uh with a normal node
okay uh yeah
it's somewhat the same here it's U what
would you need apart from the the the
the small device the The Rock five like
here you need a mbme dis okay here will
depends uh if you want to be footer
proof of if you want to build an arive
note you even can build an archive note
here with with this uh devices but will
you need at least 4 tabes for an archive
node and two gabyt for a for a normal
Noe for a full node uh you need uh an SD
car uh here please buy the best SD car
that you you can afford because it's
very important the the throughput of the
SD car and the and the
quality um of course an ethernet cable
if you want to to have the best uh
internet connection the the less
uh uh the less problems with the network
but they are very sensible to the to the
network not if want if you don't want to
lose any tation if you are going to
validate with these devices uh we
recommend to use
the theet connection of the
device and these devices are uh
especially when you are uh sinking the
first time are very hot and the the best
thing to to get a
uh uh a very quiet device is buy a case
like this with uh a passive head scene
uh the another very very important thing
is to choose a very good a highend mbmm
disc because we move from the image from
the standard Linux installation
everything that uh usually right to disk
to the mbme dis in order to keep the SD
car uh safe and health we move uh all
the things like the logs or the swap
partition to the to the MBM disc because
it's built for for brighting and the SD
car is
slower uh we have a list in your
documentation that uh with some disc
that we thought that are the best but at
the end is for us is very important we
have B experience with uh uh bath MBM
disc that we don't uh don't suggest to
buy uh I think the the the hard thing
here is uh enable port forwarding with
your if you are doing sing at home with
your locally ISP you need to open uh at
least two
ports yeah and and network as well
because we we've seen a lot of problems
that comes from from network uh for
example in Spain uh B with is quite good
it's really quite good uh fiber uh
connections uh you can uh syn and all
flawlessly uh it it work works great but
we've seen other uh countries and from
from from Europe that um they have
problems with this so yeah this is
another um another uh problem that we
are uh uh seeing with with users a small
real life example for this is the ntp
protocol uh in order to not to lose any
attestations it's very very important
that you your device is uh on time but
to the second so we change the
configuration of the ntp client here in
order to be more aggressive and uh
trying to to get in time in a very very
aggressive way the the most aggressive
way that is allow it for most of the ntp
servers in order to not lose any a
second because sometimes when you lose
one second or two seconds and maybe it's
not important in any other computer here
you can lose an attestation because of
the protocol so uh having uh low latency
in
your a good internet con at home is is
quite quite
important and we are going to start a a
live demo using our image and a real
Hardware here in order to create uh a
full node left here
um yeah we're going to the SD card
with uh in this case with a stock image
from from arbm because we want you to
see uh we are going to to launch the
script manually because we wanted to you
to see uh what's going on there uh what
the script does and and all the logs
that the uh is uh rting uh along with
installation
we
are here we are going to use our
official documentation in order to
follow the same instructions that you
will follow in order to create this uh
this installation but we are going to
step some uh skip some steps because we
are going to not here waiting for
download an image or something like this
okay uh this is our our public
recommendation you can find it in Google
or in our Twitter account it's very easy
to find but it's in R the do
uh have the same things that you see the
recommended Hardware you could see here
we have a small um specs of all the
supported uh
devices um the first thing that you when
to have uh apart from building your
device putting in the box and something
like this is to download the image you
have to choose the right image for your
device you can buy an NC a rck five or
orang P you can download the old mat I
already download it I'm just going to
see it but uh it's quite bu uh I Let's
see we are going to do a life
installation with a rock five we are
going to come
here
that's
umage okay Ro five and you can do that
here the even the the Dage I already
done it so then I'm going to do
once you download your image you could
verify that is everything is okay we
provide the the share
um hash or than to that everything is
okay is or official image and this the
the next thing is to write the image to
the SD
car by the way if someone has any
question or any doubt uh please
interrupt and and whatever I
mean for example uh those uh computers
are those mini computers are
$180 yeah cost but I've seen that for
example there are right now int
computer4 computers just TR for example
are buying for
$600 which is more or less what will
cost
with well it's a little more expensive
but uh yeah it's it's uh it's a good
question um yeah but uh for example the
uh Power of of this device is 10 BTS and
you you know that uh you have to run
this 24/7 so it's a big difference with
other devices that's for example and
there are more uh uh convenience a small
factor you you can put it in any corner
of of the of the of your house or the
road there I think
that ER any device is is fine to to run
a no I mean we are not competing uh
because we are there with that no that
are an amazing option for for running
notes but uh choices are good I mean you
know and another I think another
important thing is is to add the add
diversity to the to the network work if
you only run empty compatible processors
and you have a b like a few years ago
like it was Spectre this by who affects
the hardware direct the hardware for the
processors the inter processors mostly
but some kind of of problem with the uh
MD processors also at the end you could
would have a problem and adding armed
devices with another architecture and
another kind of of CPU processs is good
for the health of the network
divers we are looking into RIS five as
well yeah we SN it a note with a a note
not a note a GU a get note a get client
with a risk F board and yeah I think
it's very interesting that people can
choose not only uh device but uh
architecture and and have a lot of a lot
of choices to to to choose from okay I
can agree
with you mention IV
uh to keep the server on time you
mentioned like you have some specific
settings for um the time servers that
pretty aggressive can you share these
settings later on
I I I'm looking for it it's one of this
is conf uh
spee
speech
fore
speech no
I have to find it because I don't
remember in which package I build it but
let me we will see this later okay let
me yeah yeah uh thanks uh this might be
maybe a silly question but running the
uh this on the cloud like on ec2
instance is this not recommended or but
running out of nothing in the cloud yeah
like in an ec2 instance sure it's easier
but it's more expensive as well yeah
yeah and and you know the objective of
of the problem of the project the goal
of the project is that individuals uh
run notes and at home this is the but of
course uh running in the cloud is
another option and TR be would be more
expensive but at the same time you can
have it like Auto healing and things
like that nature it's okay isly not not
more expensive and at the end you will
depend in a in a company and want to to
for example not depend from five six
seven big companies around the world
that could have a big problem at the
same time uh I don't know right now but
a few years ago if uh Amazon web
services have a big strong problem uh
most of the of the nodes are running in
in in Amazon in Amazon services so at
the end you probably would have a h half
of the the of the validators are down
because Amazon has a big problem usually
they don't have a big problem of course
but you know the the main purpose of of
the blockchain is to verify yourself so
it's good to to uh can do that at home
or or with your device no no I get it
thank
you
here hey sorry uh another non another
nonrelated question uh
from where I come I come from Latin
America where we have a lot of problems
with electricity and and public services
and sometimes the light goes up like for
example Cuba had had for examp one week
without electricity so uh my question is
uh how how can I be safe that that the
for example the the that if the
electricity Falls uh the the the money I
have staked on the on the on this no are
not going to be are not going to be
slashed for example if if electricity
Falls if if I I'm running on not
internet you're meaning validators slash
yeah no validator are not slash because
of a of a blackout you just are
penalized uh if you are offline you are
penalized but uh you never get this get
lash yeah okay yeah I think I Ed the
wrong term it was
penalized if if I'm offline then I am I
going to get penalized right yep yeah
yeah but you can run a a device for
keeping the the electricity at least
some hours because you you know this is
uh very low power so you would need
maybe with small yeah an UPS yes and for
the internet that's the problem okay if
you have another source of Internet is
yeah I don't know uh that's so yeah
that's an yeah and these These are
problems that are are hardly solvable
because you know the it's infrastructure
internet uh
Power with an UPS I can room my uh my I
have four or five
devices I have four or five devices like
they this at home and with my I have
very small ups and with the small ups
and plus or my home router I can run it
uh for I think six or seven hours yeah
right but uh of course if I don't have
also connection internet connection I
get also the same time so it's not safe
for example for a Black Swan event like
uh Cuba having one week without
electricity yeah thank
you sterlink yeah yeah but
but more yeah
yeah what what's the cost of Starling I
don't I don't know I'm just
asking yeah yeah
yeah in Spain is $100 per
month yeah the the monthly monthly Con
in Spain for sink is $100 per month 100
per month so
it's but also you need a bigger
EPS
yeah Es at this point we escalating on
the re we started on
$150 something
like yeah go to the cloud
so with sing yeah you have to make a
minimum of 32 well uh actually uh this
past week uh we are staking with uh one
to 5 f with uh the CSM uh from Lio that
they released I
think two or or three weeks ago and it
was great uh we didn't release this this
configuration yet because we are testing
in in we are sticking in Main
uh I think on this device and it's going
quite well but yeah uh you can use
Lio uh we are looking into other
solutions to lower this this barrier yes
uh we have validators with the vanila
contract with 32 e
but we know every everyone can can
validate with uh uh uh 32 is is very
expensive so yeah we we are looking into
into Alternatives yes this is a priority
for
us yes uh 32 right now is a good amount
of money if you want to start to toting
like vital said yesterday is much more
that two or three weeks ago so the the
barri is increasing but like d said with
some like Lio Solutions you can put
start with one 1.5 or 1 Point 1.5 .5 uh
but I think it will be this is for Early
Access I think it will be 2.3 or 2.5 I
don't remember that's it's less but uh I
they think at the L going to if you if
you're solo Staker already you can up up
to to the 12 125 staking now yeah with
with
Lio Lio Lio community community staking
module you can search for it h it's uh
it's easy to set up if you have some
experience
validating uh it's pretty much the same
but you have to deposit on the lightos
contract instead of the uh ethereum
Foundation one and the other thing are
two or three uh configuration parameters
but it's it's easy it's easy the keys
are the same uh you you you the kids uh
the same and and yes it's it's easy and
you have a p with all the uh data and
keys and and uh rewards it's it's
nice okay U and meanwhile I was uh
writing the SD card with our image with
an RBM image and we are going to
transform this Aran image in our image
with running our init script live here
we hope this everything is going to to
Google at the end you could use a lot of
different tools to write and uh
image on SD card here the the easy way
in Linux in my opinion is using DD but
there's some graphical uh here some uh
graphical tools that going same like uh
dis image writer and balena exure for
Windows and even for Mac is also Valena
so there's a lot of different uh ways to
to write an SD card and when you have
your SD card done is like you see me
amount
it it's i e like put the SD carard in
the device that's not not so
hard and if you want
to uh PL
the the device and if you want to come
closer and let's hope that everything is
okay
no
okay something we'll start here let's
see uh demo effect life
[Music]
themo
yes let me
so again now we are going to connect uh
through
SSH and um uh launch the
script H launch the script that we were
talking about and we will see how uh
this image is turned into a an Noe uh
automatically uh
automatically no network
maybe we need to find the
IP
so in order to create the demo I have to
to start a dhtp the server in my my
computer in order to simulate my
computer as a router here but uh it's
not needed home probably your your home
router is going to give an an IP to the
device in in an automatic
way now we are
entering can see this this is the
standard this this is the standard image
from from RBM for the rock
five and now we are going to to launch a
script we have to change the
the the mirrors the mirrors yes uh we
found that the default unun to mirrors
here in in Thailand are so slow that it
makes almost impossible to create this
demo here at least in our hotel because
it's so seemly slow that at the end
simple a update it last for 15 minutes
so we are we found some mirrors closer
we hope that it is going going well here
let
me it's not a big deal only change the
the sources of the of the armian um
packages and let's start
this is the uh script for for the rock
five you can find it in in our
GitHub so you can take a
look Fern is tring with Nano because he
don't want
it
right okay I I usually don't use Nano so
so but theault arming IM don't include
the beam so I'm getting a bit stuck here
but we are going to start uh the the the
magic of the bre here is the this small
script that transform the on default
image you have you don't have to trust
us you can do this at home you don't
know the offici AR image and only wrong
this Skip and will transform it in uh uh
full if you know arm no
okay uh if you download the rematch that
will happen uh automatically the first
round the first time that you run the
the script it will transform it and do
all the needed changes to create uh this
configuration let's
see
have as sleep waiting for your router
home router giving you an
IP and let's hope that uh this new
mirrors works well here that's two
minutes
okay yeah these ones are the the fast
ones
so so
uh how much time uh did it take in in
our demo at the uh 20 minutes 20 25
minutes with uh official ports or W
ports repository it's uh here from
Thailand is last for 20 minutes here is
the best that we could find
no okay we know this is a little b m but
uh the the the first thing that this
going to do the the the script is
uh test if you have already done some
installation in your dis because uh
probably you have some problems with SD
card of the device so you have to change
but uh the initial skip takes care is
you have
um a previous installation for the
ethereum arm uh image uh it not will be
deleted deleted you have to you want to
keep your
configuration and
anything uh usually it takes 10 10
minutes once we boot your your device
with a with a new image uh it takes 10
minutes yes the the first putot is Al is
quite long it's about 10 minutes back
here the the the thing is getting really
slow uh you have to sync all the uh
information from the package mirrors
from the the this to basic distribution
but here will depend of the internet
connection here yeah and if it's close
or not very close from the sources and
the one official repositories are in in
us so are quite far and yeah definitely
not the best condition here
because networking is not the the best
here no it's it's it's updating the the
AP repositories just no the the first
the first thing that you should do when
you are going to startall anything in a
wtu Bas or Deb Bas distribution is to
syn your your computer with the the Le
latest versions of the packages and you
have to it in needs to to install some
packages and to make sure that uh
everything is okay you need to to make
an update in the last let this verion
available so you have to do it it's it's
now it's now installing some some
packages yes uh after the first syn
which the the the only the slowest one
you have already the latest version and
it will go very fast uh you uh have to
see some we think uh essential Tools in
order order to uh create your image some
tools like uh beam of course and tet for
syncing or
S uh a better C loog here
uh um at the end the most important
thing here is uh where is
the uh a jisk in order
to create a partition a partition in the
the MBM disc for first time probably you
don't have anything in your dis and you
have to create a partition in a custom
way in order to have your
um uh swap
partition and use all the uh available
space in order to have the uh sync
database of the clients at the end you
will need a lot of space to sync uh uh
to sync the blockchain
h no it doesn't start to think already
uh to syn already uh here is only
preparing the operating system to you
mean the eum no no no no no the clients
theum clients are even not
installed yeah okay uh let's so this is
maybe probably a little low level but at
the end you are going to format uh your
mbme
dis is take automatically you will
create a partition format it use all the
Ava available space in the
disk uh we use uh X4 file system you are
into Linux you will know that there are
a lot of different f file systems we are
going here
to in our opinion the most stable
because this is running 25 Ser always
uh we are going to to create two
partitions uh a home partition a b phone
partition and another partition to uh
swap space and TMP U and temporary files
like logs or something like this in
order to avoid to Bright in the SD car
anything we are trying to make the SD
card as readon as possible because at
the end is the bottleneck in this kind
of
installations we create an ethereum User
it's a decision that we made H
everything is Runing under ethereum user
in the in the computer all the clients
running with the same user ethereum all
the configuration is in ETC SL
ethereum uh we wanted to do it because
we think it's the easy way you are
running ethereum software everything is
under the etherum user and in the
ethereum configuration repository all
the clients all the layer one layer two
consens execution clients have the
configuration on the same directory so
yeah and if if something goes wrong uh
with the OS you just need to flash the
SD again and you put a new SD and you
have exactly the same uh system that you
have previously and for for example for
upgrading to a new untu version the same
you put out the micro SD you flash a new
uh image and you have everything updated
including clients uh and maybe uh it's
question of 5 10 minutes yes you don't
have to do an up this upgrade and all
this the main idea is the operating
system is in the SD card and you can
change it whenever you can but all the
configuration is in the in the internal
disk the MBM dis all the confir need is
here so you you you are not going to
lose anything if you change your
operating system you could try another
one you could upgrade it or downgrade it
on maybe you have a problem with SD card
the SD card is not good usually you have
problems writing the SD card you will
see in your logs the system train to
writing the SD card some small files and
you have some briting problems probably
the SD card is wrong or something
happens to me I put the SD card in the
wrong side
and scratch it and at the end is not not
working okay that at the end you only
have to break the IM again put it in the
device and you are going go restart and
it's okay it's now right in the swap
yeah uh it takes some time uh SW
partition uh on on on this very device
is the 32 gigs version uh you probably
you're not going to use swap unless you
are using teu because jav BAS maybe Aron
andbe yeah because most of the the other
clients are less run hungry
but we are at the end we are using that
we use a a demon Lake name it D pH Ys
that is a uh a Linux demon that creates
swap on demand so uh uh if you have
space in the dis you will create more
and more swap in demand and you are AV
to home Killers the process that's uh I
think it's a good a good idea in this
these devices that they're uh small
and they are powerful but they are small
and you probably will need uh more Swap
and you are this is dynamic swap so it's
I think we we think it's a good
idea um now this the process to G swap
we changed the some kernel variable
variables to the um for the swappiness
in order to to tell the Kel uh that use
swap in a less aggressive
way we are trying to avoid write
anything to the dis so we are trying to
to use swap in the in a less aggressive
way and we
install uh our repository we maintain of
the software all the the ethereum
clients all the etherum level one level
two clients in our main or uh Dean
repository this AP e arm. come it's
public access to Can Don clients are
devian clients they're going to St all
the all the devices but uh we provide in
our GitHub the tools that you need to
write it because you don't have to trust
us as you can see uh we use the binaries
provided by the teams the client teams
directly if you CL our repository there
is
a a vagrant
machine prepare to compile of the
clients it's a mic file that you don't
have the
repository uh run into a directory
called ethereum arm and room uh make and
we compile all the clients for you they
compile or create all the the clients
for you and you don't have to trust us
uh you could use or Dean repository but
if you don't want because okay I want to
create my own packages we provide all
the tools for Crea your your deviant
packages and uh probably it's a good
idea to to do like this it's harder you
have to know a bit more about Linux and
devian system but it's not so hard is
only it's a make file that takes care of
everything and you could look of the
code is nothing very very um uh hard to
do this it's quite
easy well and now is we are going to
install all
the the e software that we support you
could see here B Aron G uh all the
dependencies around nether mind all all
the the software that you will need to
create an not home is going to start
here in the process and when you start
an on image you could choose whatever
your client you you want to use so at
the end it's quite easy uh you Runway we
and choose two random clients it's still
stalling uh te right now the one of the
heaviest
clients and at the end of the script it
will reboot and
hopefully it will start and here on our
node and we could starting to to syn uh
I don't know we are going to choose G
Nimbus whatever you want whatever you
want you you the idea here is that you
can choose any client any client you
want you choose a consensus client you
choose a execution
client uh start the consensus service
and start the um execution service and
you are done that's the that's the
idea we going to this is for layer one
of course H Layer Two is basically the
same but you need first uh to have a
layer one uh
running uh as you know the the consensus
client uh syns with checkpoint sync so
you need a time to to get the the client
sync uh and the execution client uh last
time we we tried G uh I think it was
like uh 12
hours uh but never mind is a little
faster because uh once they keep up with
the change uh the state is sinking in
the background so you can you can have a
a a usable note in maybe for 5 hours
hour it's very
fast yeah just today we sink here in 4
hours yeah four hours here in in the
boot of stick at home boot we no bo
forwarding nothing no bo forwarding not
everything it's slower that you could do
at home but in 4 hours we have a nether
M syn was prison plus nether I think
yeah but again you can choose any client
you want teu uh nimbos nimus especially
uh good for these kinds of of devices
because it's very light uh it I think it
takes less than 1 gab of ram it's
amazing and uh yeah prism and and
Lighthouse grandine I think that we
support as well and lar grandine and lar
yeah and and for the execution side uh G
NE mine Vu uh r and
everyone uh yeah yeah right now uh
the the station of all the the the over
ended here with the layers to that uh
there are the the the layer to that we
support right now and we started to to
St uh promethus and and graan there you
will have uh um our F server running in
in your device and will see all the
right now the the official do work of
for clients and it will depends on what
client are you're running you will see
the statistics of the node and the
statistics of
the the S the get statistics or nimus
statistics all the with the
officials um uh dashboard and at the end
you will see if you graan is very useful
to to see problems at the end you will
see all the hardware stats of your
device if it's low CPUs low networks you
have problems you have know uh for
people like do inama if you have
problems with your internet connection
you will see the drops in internet
connection when you are home and you can
see via your local network all the all
the stats of your
node
um of course this is really automatic
and now it's ending with all the depend
is is in grafana grafana is already
start but we have to restart the note uh
this is
the mention
set yesterday I heard somebody
say uh four terab for an archive node no
um the problem is that the state is
growing um I think that now maybe a
fresh ink is about 1.1
1.2 uh yeah it uh grows um fast uh maybe
it will be uh okay for maybe several
months but uh now uh if you can afford
for terabytes go for four terabytes but
you can run a not with two uh yet it it
will gross network will gross all the
blockchain will grow is growing daily in
daily basis so at the end two terabytes
is okay for for now clients has uh
clients have um uh online pruning as
well now uh from just one or two months
ago so it helps to to keep the the size
low yeah it's it's nice do you load
everything right now you have someing en
how
much
right 1.99 already yeah it's hard to say
uh it's hard to say but uh with uh two
terabytes I think uh maybe six seven
months you can run good it's almost
impossible to to tell but I don't think
that you will last more than a year with
two terabytes right now you probably
will need a four terabytes for sure or
or or even bigger in in the few years
but I think we are in the birge of of
asking for for for terab yes yes for for
be for be sure for for be okay I you
want you are going to buy something
right now
okay spend a little more buy four
terabytes and you are good to go
probably for years
yes okay uh meanwhile it's still
standing there this is the uh if you
want to to to create your your packages
at home and don't trust our
repository uh we provide this make files
it's uh we use fpm is a ruby tool to
create uh a RPM or any other kind of of
uh Debian or or red hat packages in a
very easy way it's quite easy to use at
the end uh you only have to pass to the
uh to the tool some kind of variables
and you will will telling where is the
the binaries where is the configuration
files uh which is the the maintainer
which is the name of the package at the
end is qu and we will create adbm or or
our RPM package for you so you could use
these scripts to create your own uh
packages at the end is quite easy to you
clone the repository go to the uh folder
of any of the clients and write
make and will uh use make file to and
with the at the end of the make process
we you will have a debm package orpm
package and it's it's quite easy to do
we think is very well and it will take
care of the P we'll go to the uh
official repository get the lest
version uh get the latest binary UNC
compress it and create the the Devan
package for you we are we use usually
don't touch anything in the in the
clients sometimes we have to to compile
it and is always in the the make file
because the the
the the containers of the client don't
don't doesn't provide an an arm binary
for you so we have to compile it for you
but at the end uh let me see if it will
end yes uh the the the station script
send it and seems to to end way at the
end we'll we change the the password for
you um we create uh ethereum user with
an ethereum ethereum password uh we
force you to to change it and we will
reboot and we will just see you have uh
right now a full note we you going to
connect
after okay let's say I finish syncing
this Noe via normal internet after sying
the is it possible to run this via uh
via VIA
5G via
5G possibly but I cannot say uh I didn't
try uh it's possible because one think
uh
the band withd needed is much more less
so yeah I I don't know how fast is the
5G the area where I live I
have
conne and at the end is going around 50
Megs per second so at the end it will be
enough to keep the track for the
whenever it comes to networks it's it's
hard to say it's hard to
say have anybody in in the community
tried running a while in in a mobile
network yeah thank you has anybody in
the in the AR in the ethereum and AR
Community or in the other in the
ethereum small uh small server Community
Tred running this for a while on on
mobile network since well especially
here especially in in in our second
world mobile networks are sometimes more
reliable than me H it it's unable though
it's like the the mobile network is not
really reliable usually the one at least
I I did which is in London you can use
it it's actually quite fast but it's
unpredictable and you are running the
node still or or you give up give up or
I did for some time I did okay because
it was stabilized stop so it stop syn it
it uh uh gets out Gets behind the chain
and keeps up behind Okay exact so you
know I I don't know what what was
exactly the source of the problem but
you know from time to time it would just
like you know either be very slow
probably or I needed to reset the the 5G
router so I actually had to create a a
script that you know detected it turn
off the plug and turn it back on to
another Wi-Fi so it was like a little
bit n that's impossible yeah yeah so I
was like this is not like stable and
reliable so I kind of gave up but for a
moment it felt like it was really good
cuz getting 200 megabits per second you
know syncing and download which is more
than enough for for it to operate thank
you for
speak so is there speed you recomend or
reliable
uh we recommend fiber but we are aware
that uh it's not available in all
countries but uh yeah
uh again we not what have to say because
uh uh what in Spain is uh slow Network
or fast Network in other countries uh I
I we we were uh surprised because uh we
met uh afre from from Germany and he
told us that uh in Germany is awful the
in in general the the the internet
connections and it was like a shock
because you don't expect to a country
like that can have uh uh bad connections
to the Internet so yeah it depends a lot
it depends a lot and it's it's it's a
it's not only it's not only speed it's
latency also because uh I usually have
uh 100 megabits at home it's the lowest
speed that you could Co H with fiber in
Spain 100 is the lowest and I used to
have it because usually in my daily
basis I don't need more uh but when I
started to to work with the here
uh at the end 100 megabytes it come
closer if you are running more than one
Noe with one note you are okay no
problem you will sink maybe you will
last a little longer but it will sink at
the end it will works but when you start
to to play with two three four five
notes is not not enough okay uh one
con uh I don't know five six something
like this but uh
yes notes Notes too oh I run maybe 7
eight at home I have 300
megabits I I have one terabyte right now
at home and the difference is huge in
times and you know you have in your you
have at home Netflix Ando and you are
watching shows and it it runs well so
yeah I
think sorry can VPN VPN externally to
the device uh you can but uh it's not uh
it's not necessary to use it's more like
you want yourp
to yeah no it's uh I I don't I don't um
I don't uh um do anything uh particular
I mean it's the stock don't
one okay uh the only thing I don't hear
is start two Services get uh nimus it's
the nimus log so and can you show the
the both uh commands
yes uh start n consensus Cent and I
think h no I started nether mind okay
nether mind and anus and it's starting
to syn right now so you once boot with
the with a new node uh you just have to
start two services and you have
a h you will have a node in several
hours depends on on network conditions
this this wi-fi is quite fast it's
faster than the the the public the
General Public Access so probably here
in four or five hours you're good to go
so at the end of this uh when consensus
uh when uh nether M and and thinking uh
you could start what we call a supernote
we are going to start
op yeah we will start a supern it won't
work because you need an L1 uh synet
which uh is not happening now uh but we
will show the configuration files
because we need to to change a couple of
parameters it's everything it's in our
uh in our documentation page so I have a
question there about updates so when
there's a new chain Fork happening and
you need to update before that like is
that is some of that automated because
it's dbn packages is there like a crown
tab that you have already in your
recommendations so like maybe you can
talk about how long does it need to be
down should I check weekly like some
that you you use the deian automatic
updates but we don't start it by default
we don't want H to uh force you to to
upgrade anything because you could be
start working in in a verion for some
several reasons so at the end most of
the
people uh tends to wait one or two
versions behind not in the top of the
edge version because sometimes the new
versions include new books new boxs um
and we are not we think that is not very
polite to force you to to update your
packages but you could use the the deian
um the deian U demon to to upgrade your
packageing in automatic way we will uh
we usually uh update the repository the
same day or the one or two days that the
new version arrives so you will have
always the the latest version yeah wish
usually announce the the releases of of
new packages on on our TT account so you
can see that there so
um we just need because we are running
uh both uh L1 and to in the same um in
the same uh device we just going to put
Here Local
Host yeah he he can use Local Host
because one of the software that we
provide here is an N server Runing as a
proxy because most of the time that
people that R an not at home they want
to access to the API of the client in
order to do their work
or check anything in the in the in the
blockchain so at the end it's easy to to
only uh use the IP of the device to to
get information at at the end it's an NG
server running here uh like a reverse
proxy for for all the the
clients and if you are going to use uh
metam mask against your own node there
is a you have to startall there um um
and Jinx is uh running with um SSL
certification that you will have to
install in your computer in order to
trust it or if you have your
own uh Domine you could use
it
yeah so uh for
uh for uh starting the L2 we just need
to start uh this these are
uh um
um uh first you need to to run UPG and
later up no that's H all you have to do
and here and in the in the upnote
configuration you need to um put where
your L L1 is H in this case is Local
Host you you we put Local Host in in
case you have it in another node you put
here uh the IP and and you're done
will
oh
happened oh okay but no no no layer one
is
not
the uh it's an example everything is
under the ethereum uh ITC ethereum uh
folder all the configuration is there
now we need to uh specify another port
for uh for up G because G is uh running
on on
30303 so we need to change that as well
now um once you have a up all you have
to do is uh again put your uh modify
your configuration in up node and and
well uh um we are uh using optimism as a
as an example but uh you can run
Arbitron or nosis or base so it's all in
our configuration uh page so it's not
the only option
optimism can you run layer one and Layer
Two it's the super node
okay up Noe is not is not going to to
work because uh we don't have a layer
one syn
okay see it's going
to to
break but uh yeah this is pretty much
every all you can you have to do to to
run two notes two layer
notes H in the same device t
but uh yeah just to come back to that
earlier question about the storage size
now if you run two oh yeah yeah no four
four terabytes here yes so how big is
optimism for example right now like how
much do I need for that because I always
think they so fast so much yeah I I
would say about two terabytes op not
just optimism yeah yeah and and uh
several months ago uh you needed to uh
uh download the snapshot it was uh very
difficult to to the compress because H
it was already uh the snapshot was uh
huge and you
needed like six or S terabytes for
storing the the compressed file and and
and the compress it but now it supports
a snap sync and and and it works works
great yeah it's very easy to to run an
optimism node yeah we have really at
home running a super node because if
everything fails we have a at home node
is not running because it fails but uh
but uh yeah it's it's here it's at home
it's ours okay this this is running at
my home okay uh this one and you you can
see uh um the average load and it's
running
flawlessly uh it's the same I don't know
is if this is the same device
no
it's orange P by FL and um yeah it's
pretty much the same device but uh you
can see that it's running great uh in
sync
and
whats ah uh
wait a minute
please
what is should to see nice this is nice
okay as you can see here the all
the a very easy way to see how is your
uh your node going you have the all the
processes all the processes running is
up G nimus um up node all in the same
node it's an orang orange Pine is most
more or less the same device the same
powerful the same memory um you see it's
uh it's not cing the CPU is 70 70% of
CPU using memory are 60% capping is 50
50% right here is is it's doing
well not is not even very very high low
here so you can see this is more than
enough small device like this to Ru
super
yes sorry but why we you swap just some
sometimes most of the times during sync
uh you will need more memory that you
have sorry this is more than the 72 with
a super note yes with all the this one
four five six seven uh Services running
sometimes in during syn it will requir
more than 62 and will out of memory safe
measure I think that it's is not using
it Prett pry much it's not be using swap
but the swap is in the MBM disc so it's
quite fast to access this app and then I
was at uh this a very funny web page
Linux maram so at the end you have swap
because the system is is going to need
right now it's 50% uh us it not probably
let me
see no no there's no process using in
swap right now but uh during sync we saw
several on Killers we have all the
devices so we will need swap at the end
um if using the 16 gigs of RAM version
will use round we use also
but uh when everything is sink and
Runing is not so heavily us it the the
the service of course I I don't remember
you will have always a perio server
running in behind storing storing the
statistics of your note so it's always
running promeo server and grafana server
over the promethus so at the end is
another quite heavy uh uh process
running so at the end you will need a
bit of swap but it's not a big deal
because the swap is in the the MBM disc
the SS disc is quite
fast I'm lot faster than the SD card
that the main idea of this is all the
Twix for not using thisd
car okay I think that's it yeah that's
it that's the end is the way to create
your not at home I don't know if there
is any other question over here Y how
how are you running this at home how
does it look in your home exactly the
same exactly the same I have uh well not
exactly I we have a little rck uh but uh
you can put this in any Corner because
uh if you want only one note I have
maybe six seven
not a w
yes this one have a w in my case because
there is no noise so at the end you
right now I have another rack and I have
a little room for myself for work at
home but uh at the first time when I
start running it I have it uh in in the
left side of the my home router a small
I bought a very very small ethernet
cable um I only need one um uh I don't
need the screen I only need the power
adapter and the small so the end is no
noise a little bit hot but is not noise
so at the end is is have a very good W
very very good and only one yes and I I
bought this small keyboard it's quite
useful to to run this these devices you
have a mouse and a keyboard here and at
the end is is quite easy to to to work
but only if you need to to put the
screen or working prce
but yeah I don't think you will have a
problem with with it's not so ugly
absolutely and makes no noise you mean
you can actually that's the idea that
you can put it in any corner
so maybe a little but uh I think that uh
even in syn because uh one sink is uh
you you can see the low aage uh after
the sink uh it's uh it's maybe at 50
50 uh maybe uh at home in my home is
around
60 yeah I always wasn't place I was
at yes uh I have it in in a small rack
closet small rack no ventilation at all
no no no fun no noise everything is
quiet and it's around 60 always if you
touch it you will notice that it's a
little
hot yeah yeah you you could run it in a
very close Lo space and you will not
have problems and don't know it will
depends on your weather you are probably
40 50 outside I don't know I I I don't
really know but I think you can run it
inside a dra if you
want yes yeah yes yes no no
problem okay if any other
question thank you thank you thank you
sh
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
oh
SC
[Music]
oh
h
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
e for
d
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
is
for
[Music]
oh for
is
[Music]
sh
d
[Music]
a
d
[Music]
e
oh
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
w e
oh
[Music]
you're
oh
[Music]
oh e
[Applause]
[Music]
oh e
oh
[Music]
w
a
[Music]
e
a
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
and
[Music]
the
for
[Music]
sh
oh
[Music]
he
o back
[Music]
o
back
[Music]
for
in
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
e
oh
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
h
is
[Music]
oh
for for
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
e e
for
[Music]
for for
e
[Music]
all
sh
[Music]
all
oh
[Music]
your
hey everyone I think we're going to get
started
here okay
cool hey everyone uh this Workshop is
going to be about ccip read maybe I'll
hold this oh or maybe not okay also
known as ERC 3668 or maybe not okay also
known as ERC
3668 I'm Greg at inss labs and going to
be splitting this up uh with some
friends from Linea and un ruggable who
you'll be hearing from a little bit
later uh so just agenda I know this is
Workshop so we're going to try and limit
the slides but uh to keep it interesting
we're going to give you three different
perspectives I'm going to give a brief
overview uh Julian and Grant from Linea
are going to share their perspective as
kind of the first layer two team that
really built and uses trust list CCI
read infrastructure in production and
then Thomas from unrug is going to share
a more generalized framework around how
you can use uh trust list ccip read
infrastructure in production as well so
if you haven't seen it um this is ccip
read or ERC 3668 it was authored by Nick
Johnson founder developer of ens and
you'll hear why that's relevant in a
second and uh before we dive in we just
want to answer two questions today why
was it created and how is it used and I
guess before I do that has anybody uh
kind of written a contract that uses
ccip read before just to figure out the
audience okay so not very many cool this
is going to be useful introduction then
so ccip read was written with iness in
mind but written as an EIP so that it
can be used for other things as well uh
and the reason it was written with 's in
mind is because we have fairly unique
needs um ens is rooted in L1 which
obviously is decentralized but expensive
and so we wanted to have a flexible
system to where you can also uh
basically fetch data from other places
um and the first solution that people
might think about is why not just like
deploy to a bunch of chains and the
reason we're unique is because we kind
of can't do that uh there has to be one
central registry for where you haveth
names which is only a part of ens but an
important one uh and so we can't just
kind of deploy to different chains there
can't be a world in which a e name is
registered on multiple chains and
different owners is just messy so we
have to have a central chain and we it's
important for us to stay on Main net for
that Central chain uh for that central
registry because of decentralization and
stuff like that so an ideal solution to
these kind of set of problems would be
supporting reading data from any
offchain data source and we really say
offchain but it's like off L1 to be a
little more explicit so that could be uh
a database any generic API or a layer
two and at the initial level kind of
like the first level defense both of
these look the same like offchain is
just off L1 um but we'll kind of talk
about how that difference comes into
play in a minute um and similar to 0.1
based on where you read from you'll have
different sorts of verification logic um
and so if you're reading from an
offchain data source it will be a base B
verification logic if you're reading
from an L2 you want something a little
bit more complex and more kind of
provable and ultimately you don't want
to add an extra burden on app developers
that have to like do a bunch of whole
custom stuff and you also don't want um
a whole bunch of burden on Gateway
operators that might like push data to
L1 by making a transaction and basically
trying to mirror other chains because
that's just expensive and not really
sustainable so the solution is this kind
of diagram I think you can see it pretty
well uh it's small on my screen so I'll
try and explain it basically there are
three parties you have a client you have
a contract and you have a Gateway or in
other words it's like an application um
a smart contract and then an API you
know the spec is that a client will call
a function on a smart contract as you do
on any contract and instead of returning
data directly from you know internal
storage or something it will actually
return an error if you're implementing
ccip read and that error has a specific
signature basically it's it's offchain
data error and this indicates to the
client that it should send the call data
that it gets back from that error to
some URL which is also defined in the
error and this kind of sounds complim
complicated but it's handled
transparently under the hood uh by a
bunch of popular libraries probably the
ones that we all love and use today like
VM ethers wack me and so on um but
basically VM ethers wag me they know how
to handle this response and it's
deferring a request to an API a Gateway
that Gateway will return some response
and then again the client basically
submits that response to the originating
smart contract asking it to verify the
result and so that verification is where
the cool stuff happens but just to give
a more ens Centric view of this we have
a client which you could also call like
a wallet in this case you know say
you're trying to send assets to example.
e the resolver is a smart contract um in
ens resolvers are what's responsible for
storing all the data associated with a
name and then again Gateway and you have
implementation specific logic so I want
to look up example. eth on the resolver
smart contract it reverts with an
offchain lookup saying I don't have that
data but actually go get it from this
offchain Gateway it asks the Gateway it
reads it from whatever logic that
Gateway implements Returns the data
verifies it and ultimately you get your
result so the two kind of like cool
pieces here are the Gateway can do
anything and the call back verification
can do anything so the two most common
implementations are like on the Gateway
side you can either fetch data from a
database or you can fetch it from a
layer 2 and then the corresponding
verification would be like signature
verification so does the private key of
my gateway kind of approve this message
very basic very trusted and then if
you're reading from layer 2 it's really
does the has the layer 2 posted its
state root domain net you know the way
rollups are supposed to work and does
the L1 kind of verify that data that
it's received and so we're just going to
go through two quick examples and show
like a before and after of what this
enables I'm not actually going to run
through both but I'll just do one very
quickly so you can kind of feel the
difference um I have this
offchain demo here I'm going to say hi
Devcon offchain demo. this name does not
exist on ethereum obviously I'm just
going to Press Register
and oh that makes sense okay give me one
second okay I didn't think that
through
yeah
um okay if I can't do this in a second
then that's fine all right I can't do it
but anyways
if you want to scan this QR code and do
it yourself what's happening is I'm
signing a message and that gets saved to
a database and once it's saved in a
database then you can go and use this as
an ens name because it's just like uh
signing my my Gateway signs a message
kind of like saying that it's correct
and then if you go to the name. offchain
demo. eth in the en manager app or any
wallet or block EXP or anything like
that it will work for free and um I
wanted to show you that so it's a little
hard to explain but hopefully you
understood
um and while you guys might be playing
around with that I'm just going to talk
about the kind of like better approach
which is the trustless trustless example
and this is what Linea does so you'll
hear more about it in a second but
instead of storing the data in a
database and instead of the Callback
function verifying you know a generic
signature it's stored on a layer two on
Linea and the Callback function verifies
linea's State proof that is or state
rout that is posted to layer one as
normal rollups do and in this case the
Gateway can actually never lie uh
because it's verified on the layer one
smart contract so this is like the best
way to do ccip read and what you'll be
hearing more about how to do in a little
bit from from both of the teams so the
before and after from in's perspective
is like creating an L1 subname which I
tried to do this morning subname dog
test . eth metamask was telling me it
would cost $15 to do that whereas also
this morning if I wanted to register
greg. line. which the screenshot is from
a little while ago so might be slightly
different but it costs 10 cents and both
of these work the same way across any
ens integration one is $15 one is 10 and
so this is really what we wanted to
solve when creating ccip read and how
it's being used in public is pretty cool
um you know Linea has almost 500,000
names b. eth has 500,000 names and these
other two offchain implementations have
millions as well and so basically ccip
read was created to solve flexible data
for ens and also the ethereum ecosystem
at large reading layer 2 Data from layer
one and now I'll hand it off to the line
team to go a little bit deeper uh we
haven't practiced the computer switch so
might have to give us a minute but let's
see how this goes
[Applause]
mirring by
default this is what they're okay yeah
that's
cool down
good afternoon everybody uh my name is
Grant I'm one of the lead smart contract
engineers at linear as part of the core
team if you want to scan that QR code
that's going to take you to the link for
this repository where it'll contain the
code samples with everything that we're
going to be working through today so
I'll just give you guys a minute to grab
that and then I'll take you through some
bits and pieces about the linear
implementation with the s and then once
I'm done Julian is going to take you
through an actual practical example so
if you're wanting to code along that's
the repository to get the data from you
may need to install a couple packages
that are in there
first as with good security practice
just make sure those are the packages
that you want to
install
cool hopefully that's big enough to see
let me just make it a bit bigger
there we
go so looking at the ens implementation
that we've done on the left hand side
you can see the user icon that user is
going to then call a smart contract on
L1 as Greg was explaining earlier in
this case it's the on the bottom that's
the L1 resolver what that implements and
inherits from is the base fetcher
contract which is an abstract contract
package that we've written and that
anybody is able to use to call and do
all the reverting that was mentioned
earlier and that follows the ccip
Gateway well ccip um
EIP that then returns back and then goes
to the Gateway that you can see on the
bottom over there which then goes and
calls some data on linear what is what
it's doing in our implementation it goes
and gets a storage proof
and data at a specific storage slot that
you've specified in our example today
we're going to be calling a single
storage slot just to get some data out
of there and returning it to L1 it's
fairly simple in what it's doing but
some of the partners like un ruggable
you will see they've done some examples
around retrieving more complex data such
as structs and various other things so
the example here that we're doing is
quite simple but you can build on it and
do pretty much any data that you want
there what that does is it gets the
current storage route and comes back to
L1 and because as part of our linear
finalization process when we roll up
we've taken the storage route we've
started on L1 at a particular block
height and then when you come back to L1
back to the resolver or in this case
it'll just be our Vera fetcher verx is
our proof of humanity Gateway well
Solution on linear so for example if you
want to use proof of Humanity on L1 you
can jump straight into our linear
implementation or the verax
implementation and then use that so
there's something for you to think about
using in the future if you're doing some
things on L1 so we then call back to the
resolver on L1 once we hit L1 we then
take the storage proof check that it
matches against the state that has been
stored from from the finalization
process and then you can do with with
the data whatever you want to know one
so it's like you've proven Humanity in
our case we've going to pull out an
attestation to prove that that
attestation on verx
exists and I think that's it's up to you
you want to go through the code repo
there are some other links in here
through our ens implementation that's in
the repository so at your leisure have a
look see through the implementation if
you want to go and get a deeper
understanding of of what we've done and
obviously this has all been very well
audited
cool
I'll hello everyone um so yeah we we
will uh go through an example um as
Grant was saying um an example that is
going to uh read data uh on Linea in um
the verax
registry um so I'll I'll do it uh live
right now um but you guys can follow the
quick start that we have here and you
can redo everything that we'll be doing
right
now
um so
first um we're going to go through a a
little bit of code I don't know if
you okay you think it's I think it's
good enough can everybody see the screen
can you
is this
good um so what we have is um uh the
fetcher contract so here this this
fetcher
contract um has to match your uh your
needs uh so you're going to have to
write a custom fetcher contract for um
what you going what you are going to
read on the the uh destination chain so
here we want to we want to read a data
from verax contract so that's why we
call it we call it the verx fetcher and
this uh contract is going to inherit
from um uh this evm fetch Target
contract where all the U verification of
um the data that's going to be U uh that
will that will be sent by the Gateway
along with the proof um all this
verification process will happen in in
this evm fetch Target contract but this
um uh is
in I mean we made an npm package of it
so you can can just um uh use it uh from
there and so all you have to do uh is a
couple a couple sorry a couple um
uh uh uh you have a couple um arguments
to enter here uh so this will be uh the
verifier and the and the Target contract
so the verifier will will be the uh um
contract that does the
verification and um but this is already
deployed so you can use the same for all
your uh custom
Fetchers and uh the address Target uh
this is the uh address contract on uh uh
on
L2
um then we have this uh um we have to uh
also uh implement this uh function here
um
this is because there's a delay in the
finalization of the from linear to A1 uh
that can be from 8 to 32 hours before
the the state of Linea is posted on on
on A1 so we um so we give the uh
verification process uh an accepted
block range length um
so uh because
we can uh we cannot uh directly um uh
get the the data on the the latest block
on linear um if it if it hasn't been um
posted on
L1 uh so that's why we have this uh L
accepted length here
um and so F and finally this is the r
function where we're going to uh trigger
the ccip flow uh ccip read flow um
so what matters here is the what we call
the slot that we going to we that we are
going to query uh on the on the linear
contract um sorry so we we'll get the
slot 102 in verx in verx registry
contract um and uh I won't go too much
into detail of how we uh build this
Square here uh but this is a um this is
mainly the ens implementation of the evm
gate Gateway that they they did this way
so I I'll let I'll let you go check the
more in details
um and uh and yeah this and finally this
is the uh function that's going to be
called um once
the um the data has been sent from the
Gateway and uh and uh after the
verification uh we'll just call this
call back function to return the the
final
result
um so I'm going to deploy this contract
right now I'll just do
this hopefully it will
work uh obviously obviously the uh verx
registry on lineer that we are going to
query uh it's already deployed uh and
also for the purpose of this demo we we
had to have a already deployed contract
we cannot deploy a new contract because
otherwise we would have to wait between
8 to 32 hours that the state is posted
on N1 so so that's why we are quering um
a contract that already exist on
email it's taking a bit of
time so this is on SE by the way uh
we're doing this one
SE
okay I mean if I can use
it
yeah um I'll Just sh I mean okay finally
done so uh I'm going to get my deployed
address
here um and I'm going to show you a
little UI very simple that we made uh to
call this contractor that we just
deployed so I'm going to paste uh the
address the deployment address here and
what I'm going to do is U I'm going to
check if uh an attestation ID stored on
uh on the uh verx registry
exists um so on linear
so I'll just do uh so the idea is this
this one I'm going to just call the uh
the contract like this and uh what it
does it Returns the same ID so that
means that it does exist if I put
another let's say uh this ID
here um it will tell me that this um ID
this attestation ID does not exist um
and what we can also uh see
is when uh when I call the uh the
contract I can see here that uh we have
a call I don't know I don't know if they
can see I guess it's too small but I
can um we can see that there so the
linear ccip Gateway is being called uh
in the background when we uh click this
button um
part part of the process of the CCI
period um and it returns so a bunch of
data so it's it's the it's the value
that we are um trying to retrieve plus
the proofs and all this um all this data
here is sent is a
sent
sorry why can
okay okay um is sent to
uh this function here this SCB back
function here um where uh it's going to
decode all the all this data and uh is
going to uh prove the to is going to uh
prove that this this data is this data
is
valid and then uh and then send it back
to uh this callback function here and
return the value
um so yeah this is all the
uh uh all the CCI per flow
um and
uh and yeah that's and so the other
thing like I wanted to show you um is
uh how oh sorry this is not
it um how easy it is to U uh for the
client to do the ccip call
um just going to show you
uh so this is by using U um ether JS for
examp for example uh you can simply do
this uh uh call here uh where you're
going to uh so you're calling the method
that's uh to get attestation method you
pass it the attestation ID and you just
add this little parameter here in a
enable ccip read and in the background e
in the background ejs going is going to
um do all the ccip read flow
so uh so rever uh so it's going to catch
the revert the revert from uh
um from the contract then he will take
uh this uh uh then he will call the
Gateway that need he needs to call to
fetch the data and then send and then U
take the take the DAT data back from the
Gateway and do all
and recall the
uh call the call back function to verify
the data and and then and return the
result so this is uh yeah uh this is all
that's happening in the background
um and yeah I think that's uh what else
did you you want to show um I so I was
also um telling you at the beginning
that uh uh you going to need well here
we already have the the slot that we are
interested in when I talk when I talk
about
slots uh it's um so the the storage on
evm there there's a storage index index
for every uh variable that is that is
stored so for example if we took a look
at the uh adest station registry that we
are
querying um what we are interested about
uh in is is uh
uh go back here it's this uh variable
here so we need to uh we need to get the
the slot index of this variable here um
you uh you can do it uh you can
calculate it uh yeah you can calculate
it manually but uh you Al you also have
a for example with hard that you have
a uh you have a plugin that allows you
to do this uh
easily
um you can do
uh NP
npx hard to check so this is going this
this common here is going to use um um
hard hard that storage layout
plugin uh and when I do this it's going
to uh display all the uh slot index for
all the variables in a contract that we
are interested in and so you can just uh
uh get the the index that is um uh
interesting for you and uh and uh use it
in your fetcher
contract so yeah I think that's a cool
plugin
um and uh yeah I think that's
uh that's about it for U this work
through um so yeah you can reproduce
everything following the uh
um the quick start here uh on your
machines and uh yeah I think uh do we do
questions uh no
or I don't
know okay yeah we do questions at the
end or okay yeah at the end all right
well I give we'll give a
[Applause]
we'll be around I'm just telling that
we'll be around to answer questions and
also like the system having issues
getting yeah
perfect okay how
does I've given you a teaser already
accidentally
okay uh perfect I am
Thomas from unrug uh we are ens service
providers uh we are building unrug
gateways which is a more generic uh
system for doing essentially what the
guys from Linea have just
demonstrated so unrug gateways is a full
solution for allowing trusted dat
trusted data resolution from L2
blockchains just quickly if I'm here can
everyone hear me yes yeah
perfect so this is a QR code that links
through to our GitHub repo uh I would
recommend clicking on that at this point
I will do it just for the purposes of
demonstration um but at the top of here
we also have a link through to our
Gateway documentation which is also good
supplementary material for this
presentation and I've specifically set
up a Devcon links section which links to
everything that I'm going to kind of
mention here so you can kind of follow
along as we go or you can uh jump ahead
if you wish and just click on everything
and see what
happens so a bit of background and
context to why we have built unrug
gateways so unrug is an enss service
provider and we are building on top of
ens we are building a solution that
allows for reading data from L2
chains the usage of that in the context
of ens is of course uh for allowing data
to be stored on cheaper chains that make
it easier and more accessible for
users we also want to make Building
Solutions simple and accessible to
everybody so that Builders such as some
of you in here uh easily able to kind of
onboard and build smart contracts that
integrate um with the way solution to to
read data from other
chains we yeah we want to abstract away
complexity and avoid duplication of
effort for some additional background
the code that the linear guys just ran
through is uh a fork I believe of the
evm Gateway codebase which was kind of
the initial version of this solution
that was built by Nick Johnson I think
Greg mentioned that um from within ens
Labs that kind of worked with arbitrum
and optimism I believe and then Linea
kind of got in contact and wanted to
build a verifier solution for their
chain and there was a lot of back and
forth and a lot of kind of uh hard work
on both ends to get that working so I
guess in many respects this is to kind
of uh take out some of that boilerplate
leg work in terms of other chains
getting on boarded and making it easier
for uh chains to work with the solution
but also implementers to use the
solution so as you can see in the
screenshot and if you click on this
link this is the ens app um this is the
profile for arbitrum verifier
unreal. this data is all metadata that
is being resolved from arbitrum
trustless uh so this data is returned
from the gateways that we operate uh
alongside proofs which are then verified
on layer one so this data is quick and
easy to update it's cheap to update uh
and it's trustless the worst thing that
anybody can do in terms of a Gateway
operator is that they could censor data
so they could stop any proofs being
returned but they could never return
anything that's invalid or incorrect so
that should give confidence to users
that if someone is inputting ANF s name
into a a transaction uh input the name
that it resolves to is in fact the name
that's set and as long as they trust
their uh client metamask for example
which one probably does at this point um
then yeah you're you're all
good so I mentioned evm Gateway uh the
code base that Nick originally wrote
what is new in ter terms of what the
unrug Gateway solution
offers firstly uh NX solution only
allowed for uh single targets so you
could only fetch data from an individual
smart contract this uh solution allows
for you to work with as many contracts
as you want there is a constraint but
it's not a constraint that in practice
anyone's ever going to reach so what
that means is you could in principle
query a contract
read data from that contract that is an
address of another contract use that and
Target that and then fetch data from
there in the context of ens this is
particularly useful because the current
architecture of ens has a registry which
has a resolver set for each name and
clients that implement the ens standards
have to fetch that resolver for that
name then query that resolver to resolve
and
address this allows for you to use this
solution to get that data from layer
twos and still kind of maintain all the
benefits that I mentioned before with
trustless this solution is also heavily
optimized we've spent a lot of time
implementing caching at all layers uh
We've uh optimized on request size I'll
come back to a reason the reason why
that's important later uh we have RPC D
duplication so in terms of getting proof
data from the various chains rather than
having many many calls to e get proof
and Linea get proof and ZK sync get
proof which are the respective proofing
methods implemented by those chains we
can kind of group together requests and
uh min minimize kind of data that's
going over the wire we also use assembly
wherever appropriate to optimize uh and
make everything efficient in terms of
operation flexible data manipulation you
can do everything in line you can write
a request and uh you can C at cache you
can use bitwise operations you can slice
you can do maths operations this means
that you can kind of do incredibly
complicated things if anyone's looked at
the ens architecture in its current form
it uses name hashes which uh are KAC
concatenate KAC hashes of concent name
ated label hashes um and you can now
produce a name hash in line in your
request and then query data from a slot
using
that you can also use nested requests so
you could build a request pass that into
another request Loop over it etc etc and
for incredibly large data values stored
on chain there's also a big unlock with
hashed bytes storage
I will escape I'll escape this just
quickly to link through to this
documentation page in the solidity
documentation this refers to how storage
is laid out in solidity and the guys at
Lena mentioned this there's some kind of
incredibly complicated rules about how
different storage types are stored on
chain and what un ruggable gateways
seeks to do is essentially abstract that
complexity away from you so you can
write a very simple request and request
data and have it come back without
having to understand all of the
intricacies of how everything is laid
out behind the
scenes so chain support in principle we
support all orbit chains all super chain
chains Linea scroll bass I put Bas on
there separately but base is in fact a
super chain chain and of course the
recently announced name
chain so this slide is intentionally
verose and complex Tri structures fault
proofs finalization it's all fairly
complicated stuff and again we want to
make ccip read and reading data from
other chains as accessible and as simple
as possible so we kind of try and
Abstract away the fact that all of these
chains use different triy structures
different fault proof mechanisms
obviously optimism arbitrum are
optimistic rollups scroll and Linea ZK
rollups scroll uses Poseidon hash for
its TR Keys Linea uses a sparse Merkel
try etc etc we want to create a simple
Builder interface that allows you to
write one data smart contract that you
can deploy on any of these chains and
then use a simple Builder interface to
build a request to fetch that data on
any chain without having to understand
any of these
intricacies I do make note of the
finalization periods op optimism main
net actually this is not true for all op
stack chains because it's configur
configurable but optimism mainnet has a
3. 5day finalization period orbit Chains
It's 7 Days scroll is an hour and as the
linear team mentioned it's currently 8
to 32 hours although I do believe that
they're seeking to reduce that over
time another area of complexity is
rollup
architecture on layer one all of these
chains have incredibly complicated
rollup contracts that kind of intertwine
with one another the fult proof uh
chains inherently have more complicated
architectures where lots of contracts
interact with one another and scroll for
example uses batches of blocks uh that
is to say the data that they commit to
layer one is contained within contains
batches um which is kind of a range of
blocks whereas most of the other chains
submit State roots that align
specifically with an individual block so
again we want to kind of abstract this
away so people don't need to work out
exact L how to prove against State Roots
post on posted on L1 by a particular
chain instead they can just use a
standardized interface and it will just
work so a bit more Hands-On the core
components of the solution essentially
if you're writing a smart contract for
example ANS resolver whereby you want to
resolve data from another chain you need
to write a request you'd write that
request EST using our Builder interface
which I'll will come on to shortly that
request will then be sent off to a
Gateway we operate gateways for example
randomly selected arbitrum Gateway arbit
room. gateway. unrug bl.com
so if you go onto these gateways on the
landing pages it just gives you some
configuration information which will
probably mean nothing to you and that is
fine but the Gateway solution will
abstract everything away and these gate
ways will return responses which contain
proofs that it will then verify in the
third part which is the verifiers that
are deployed on layer
one if I click on this documentation
link this the documentation uses the
solution itself and it resolves all of
these metadata addresses from the
respective chains so this address here
is resolved from arbitrum this is
resolved from Bas this is resolved from
optimism a and scroll we also have
spolia
deployments which hopefully will also
work they do um so these are the
addresses that you need to use if you
want to write a a smart contract that
utilizes this
solution similarly we've set up verifier
d metadata. rug. e which when it loads
contains the addresses of the metadata
contracts on these respective l2s so
these are the contracts where this data
is actually being the data that you see
here is being fetched from these
contracts so if we click through to one
of
these we can have a look on the optimism
eepa
scan this is a fairly simple contract
whereby you configure it with a verifier
address and in a array of key value text
records but if we go to here and read
the
contract we can see that the verifier
address for this one is rx 61 text
record if we type in avatar for
example
yeah oh no
is that better yeah so this is the
Avatar that is being resolved when you
visit that
um address on here which
was arbitrum do verifier do un ruggable
I know maybe it was the optimism
one yeah so R x61 and that's the avatar
so this is probably the bit that's of
more interest in terms of if you want to
actually build something using this
solution so this is the Builder
interface that's made available to users
of the code
base I'll just run through it quickly so
this is essentially stating that you
want to build a request that's
requesting one output so one piece of
data we're setting the address of the
contract which we want to resolve data
from which is the metadata contract that
we have deployed on the layer two we're
then saying that we want to get the data
that's in slot one and we're reading
that data we're then setting it into
output index
zero
so similarly to the previous uh example
by the linear team if you go over
here what's happened there
in slot zero we have the owner because
this is a notable contract in slot one
we have the verifier address so that is
why we're fetching from slot
one that
is the actual code that is
utilized
by if you just bear with me
the unrug unrug verifier resolver which
is the resolver that we've set on
verifier unrug doe so if you're aware of
the various ens IPS and the ens uh
protocol standards there's ens IP 10 and
ens 5 ens iip 10 is for wild card
resolution so we set this resolver on
verifier unrug B.E and then all subnames
of that get passed through to this
resolver if we look here the code that I
had in my presentation is is listed here
in the adder getter and we pass through
this request to the fetch method it
comes back to this call back and we
return the value and that's it
so hopefully people are in agreement
that this is somewhat more simple
although I appreciate that it's still
inherently complex than kind of having
to discern exactly how storage slots are
laid out for a particular contract or
the fact that kind of a long string
spans multiple slots or that if you're
trying to read from a mapping you have
to work out the hash of the key etc
etc behind the scenes this request is
converted to these bytes which represent
the request and are interpreted by our
virtual machine hopefully again
everyone's in agreement that the former
Builder
um syntax is more easily more easy to
read and more semantically clear than a
long heximal string in the same way that
an ens name is a lot easier to use than
a heximal address
so the virtual machine behind the
scenes you kind of don't actually need
to be concerned with this because this
is what abstracts away the complexity
for you but just as a matter of interest
it's a stack based virtual machine it's
written in both typescript and solidity
so if you want to develop quickly you
can write code in typescript and then
the same syntax will work in solidity so
you can build tests and examples using
node for example run them make sure they
work then just copy and paste them into
your solidity deploy off you go
essentially when it comes down to it it
is just uh multiple if statements um but
if you do look through the code base
you'll see that kind of behind the
scenes there is a lot of complexity to
it the majority of the Builder interface
methods are essentially for Discerning
the appropriate storage slots from which
to read data and then behind the scenes
the virtual machine generates the
storage slots and reads the
data that is all that I have for you
um this is the QR code for our GitHub
again and uh if you do work with this
codebase and if you have a look through
it and you like it and you want any help
we're more than happy to help a star
would be appreciated thank you any happy
to answer any questions or fill in any
blanks um yeah just wanted to kind of
focus it down a bit and uh if there's
any additional understanding that you'd
like I'm happy to elaborate and
similarly I'm sure Greg and uh Arthur
and Julian would be happy to answer any
questions directed their
way
Thomas
oh oh
okay why there is a
need could the person that submitted
that question add any color to what
exactly they mean I'm not sure quite
follow
was was it you
Greg um so I don't know who asked it I I
did not um and I don't fully understand
but I think the question is basically
asked is like uh was interpreting what
we were saying as this has to be
implemented into an ethereum node uh
because it says something about adding
this implementation to an ethereum node
but really the whole point of this is
that you don't have to modify ethereum
nodes uh this is a a client level spec
and so wagm ethers VM uh and all the
other kind of ethereum libraries know
how to interpret that offchain lookup
error and we'll do it on the front end
the request that is or like the URL
that's sent from the smart contract back
to the client uh is is a front-end level
thing and the the front end or like
let's say the client because it could be
on a back end um we'll basically make
that HTTP request there are no changes
to nodes there's no special node or like
RPC that you need to use in order to
support this it's all client level
implementation so I think that was the
question and that's what might be more
specific to
you perfect so a thank you uh is it
possible to create a proof I the owner
transfer ownership and submit the proof
uh I'm assuming this is being asked in
the context of an ens name um so these
Solutions are kind of read Solutions so
they're read operations so you can't
actually kind of modify any storage
state or anything like that in relation
to
um the the proofs that are returned you
could kind of read from in for example
the case of name chain once it's
released you could read from name chain
to discern who the owner of a name is
and you could prove that on layer one
you wouldn't be able to then modify that
or transfer the name in any capacity
no I believe that's all of the questions
unless there's any other
us the only other thing I would add to
that is in addition the documentation
for unrug gateways is fairly fleshed out
so we do have an example section which
um has a examples utilizing our
typescript virtual machine so you can
kind of check out that repo and get
things running immediately similarly
there's solidity examples that do
specific examples with ens name
resolution and as demoed if you go onto
the ens app and look up any of these
names if you go to the root name
verifier unrug doe for example and have
a look at the resolver you can see how
that works
um by looking there and
uh yeah there's there's contact details
details on how to run a Gateway etc etc
um a more kind of in-depth overview of
the fundamentals and the concepts that
uh I've spoken about today um yeah
perfect oh
thank you I just want to ask a question
there was a
you
Windows does that mean in practice
you're to L1 does that mean there's a
delay before the that state can be read
or does it mean that the state hasn't
been
finalized so that's actually a really
good question um and
given how much time I spent working on
this it's unbelievable that I forgot to
mention this um so yes in terms of uh
orbit chains for example there's a 7day
um finalization period whereby uh any
ongoing dispute and the dispute
resolution process means that you can't
really truly believe that state stored
on arbitrum is finalized until 7 days
has passed in the context of of ens if
you had your data on arbitrum you
updated the address that it resolves to
that wouldn't be particularly useful or
functional if you had to wait 7 days and
if for that 7-Day period people sending
e for example to that address we're
still sending it to the old address in
inverted commas what the Gateway
solution allows for is for you to
configure things such that you can um
change the the sort of time period over
which you consider something trustable
so in practice for a low stake value
potentially like the description field
on a an ens name for
example there isn't really an attack
Vector there and there's certainly not
an issue with kind of loss of funds so
you could potentially run a Gateway that
says that stuff that's submitted to
arbitrum is instantly accepted and then
once you update it the verifiers will
verify those proofs and it will work
that's kind of a configuration option
and in the context of ens related
Solutions it's still kind of an ongoing
debate because in
practice uh after a certain period of
time 95% of time I just made that stat
up by the way everything is okay nothing
ever gets reorganized there aren't any
attacks etc etc um so Discerning what
the appropriate way of doing that uh and
the time periods for a chain uh and the
gateways that you operate is kind of one
of those discussions we're also
cognizant of the fact that most people
don't want to run their own gateways and
that is kind of exactly one of as well
as building this we operate gateways
with specific configurations to make it
easier for people to use and I guess our
hope is that this is one of these things
that kind of pushes uh chain operators
in the direction of of optimizing their
solutions to minimize finalization times
as listed here scroll for example with
an hour finalization that's kind of
makes scroll an attractive option Linea
8 to 32 hours I know that they're
reducing that over time which will make
them an even more attractive option op
stack and orbit chains I know that
there's a lot of research going on about
adding in ZK stuff to make it such that
you don't need to rely on their proof
system and there's potential for multi
proofs um and yeah all all of these kind
of chains the hope is that they will
work to reduce these times
essentially any
more I just I just want to add one thing
to your question so it really does
depend a lot on your use case so if
you're doing something like proof of
humanity that's based on an address like
we have with our verx Solution that's
not going to change so if you're looking
for data that you know is potentially
mutable then you know you'll have to
adjust your you know what conditions you
care about but for things that will
never change like oh this happened this
was an event that existed there's
something that you know was you know you
have proof of humanity those things will
never change so it really does depend a
lot on your use case
cool um we'll be around here for the
next like half an hour or so so if you
are working on trying to get your
Solutions working and you have any other
questions we'll be over here happy to
help you out uh if you have any
problems
[Applause]
cool up
[Music]
h
brother
I
h
[Music]
know
three round
[Music]
s e
h
[Music]
for
is
[Music]
for
n
[Music]
oh
o oh
[Music]
o
[Applause]
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
for
o
[Music]
oh
for
[Music]
in
oh
[Music]
one one by one
right both of you talking one by one
yeah there'll be a sequence of five of
us actually but we'll just come one by
one to the same slide
show okay
[Music]
all
right all right hi everybody thanks for
coming uh can we actually all please
come into the center of the room since
it's a smaller group
and can all the uh people who have been
part of the summer protocols program
raise their hands or just stand
up stand up all right do not be in one
cluster please please distribute
yourself I do not want to see two sop
people in the same breakout group so sop
people please spread yourselves
out all right people trickling in uh as
you can see from my hat it's my birthday
today so make this Workshop a
success it's not it's not just my
birthday it's a big one it's
50 so how this Workshop goes is going to
be the predictor the rest of my life
so please make it go well okay
uh all right welcome this is the
hardening the commons uh
Workshop um if you were at Tim talk
yesterday you heard him raise the theme
it's been part of like um many of the
talks here the cipher Punk history uh
session so whole bunch of talks had
these teams going so this is a workshop
and it'll be have like some talking but
it's mainly a working Workshop
and this is a research Workshop we are
not here to teach you anything you are
here to help us do some research so we
have we have what we think is a good
question it's one of the most important
questions uh how to harden the commons
um is in our opinion one of the most
important research questions and this
has been validated by like two years of
the summer of protocols program and
we're hoping that in the next 3 hours
you guys will help us come up with some
really good answers right and this will
um actually oh sorry oh sorry
okay um so this will actually help us
shape the agenda for the 2025 program so
this is not just going to be like you
know you do some exercises on paper and
it then vanishes into uh the void and
nothing else happens so please uh we
will be collecting the workshop output
we will be analyzing it and we'll be
trying to make use of it to shape the
2025 program if you don't know what
summer protocols says go to sumpro decom
or talk to the various program alumni
who are scattered around the room
all right let's
see okay
oops so the goal of the workshop is to
try and put together everything we know
and have been talking about for years in
the ethereum community you know sensor
capture and sensorship resistance
decentralized governance permissionless
Innovation how do you put this all
together in a big picture model and what
we calling a capability maturity model
raise your hand if you've heard the term
capability maturity model 1 two 3 four
five so if this had been one of my
traditional you know big Corporation
Consulting gigs and I had asked a
question 100% of the middle managers
would have raised their hand because
this is like standard LinkedIn
boilerplate business management stuff it
it can feel very like um awkward and
bureaucratic but it's a very useful way
to put lots of random thoughts together
in a model so this is a capability
maturity model workshop I'll show you a
few examples to see what that means uh
and if we do a good job it can serve as
a road map for a lot of people trying to
adapt the Technologies we've been um
we've been all working on so Harden the
common so two terms there Harden is in
two senses one as in Harden technology
against threats like you know radiation
hardening uh electronics for space
missions that's one sense of Harden the
other sense of Harden is the ability to
make strong commitments about the future
and this is something Josh Stark will
talk about in his provocation in um like
an hour or so so uh and the commons of
course you've all heard the term Commons
and we have a lot of examples in our
mind so you know ethereum L1 is a
Commons open source projects are commons
uh forests and lakes and rivers are
commons so we want to like think broadly
about Commons and uh Trent is here he'll
be actually leading a breakout session
on how to think about Commons but here's
some examples to keep in mind and I've
put this icon on some of the slides
because for the workshopping pieces
it'll be helpful to have these lists
handy so take pictures of the slides
where I have these um sort of like
prompty things um available
okay so these are some examples of
Commons don't worry too much about the
definitions systems for producing or
stewarding shared resources is a good
enough working definition for our work
here okay all right how how many of you
have heard of Elanor
ustam okay this is impressive like more
than half the room Nobel Prize winner
did some amazing work on how Commons are
built and stewarded these are her famous
principles for stewarding Commons
there's a little bit of a cult or
religion aspect around umram so don't
take this as a gospel but take it as a
thought stutter they're good ideas but
feel free to contradict and challenge
them okay so again another picture
taking
slide we do have a shared G Drive uh
where hopefully you'll dump your final
CMM model so you'll be working on paper
you'll be like making revisions of the
model that you're working on but the
final one take a picture and dump it in
this folder if you have trouble uh just
hand your paper model to Timber Timber
are you here raise your hand can you
stand up and show your face to everybody
so Timber is going to be running
Logistics in the room okay so that's the
housekeeping done so the agenda is I'll
give you a quick introduction to what
CMM are then we'll do a set of five
alternating provocations and breakouts
so short like 7 Minute lightning talk
type thing followed by 17 minutes where
you'll do one pass through the CMM um
then another talk and so on so we'll do
that halfway through we'll take a little
bit of a break and then we'll come back
do some share backs broad room comments
and then wrap up so standard Workshop
structure but hopefully the content is
what will make this okay okay so short
tldr version of hardening the commments
problem right how many of you have are
seeing this cartoon for the first time
raise your hands okay so most of you
have seen this cartoon right so you
don't want to be too idealistic we are
not writing science fiction we are not
writing weird time machine stories we
are being realistic so any speculation
we do has to be kind of like plausible
and realistic which means yeah don't get
into like weird fantasy scenario about
cryptos keep the you know uh $5 wrench
condition in mind that's what it means
to harden a common against attacks you
should be able to defend against $5
wrench attacks okay what's the CMM it's
a well-known model that management
Consultants like me and uh you know
career bureaucrats use to just think
about how organizations acquire and
learn capabilities by Rising through
several levels over several years okay
so we need to adapt it a little bit to
apply to Commons and open kind of
systems but I think it works and yes it
can be you know LinkedIn middle manager
if it's done poorly but I think
this room can do it well okay because
remember it's my birthday you have to do
it well as a gift to
me okay so here's like a classic if you
Google CMM this is the kind of diagram
you'll find it's a pyramid with levels
you start out with an initial condition
of skills where maybe there's random
skills people have like crappy
disorganized ways of doing things like
you know all of us using web3 wallets I
would say we are in this initial
disorganized level managed is when
there's a little bit more structure is
coming in then defined people have like
textbook definitions of what things are
then people are beginning to measure
things so things are getting
quantitative then finally people are
starting to optimize things like you
know this is the mature stage so this is
a generic CMM
template here's another way to visualize
one you can think of it as like a ramp
increasing in time so this one happens
to be about analytics so this type of
diagram was popular about 10 years ago
when people were talking about analytics
so as you can see the maturation is when
your capabilities are very primitive you
can only do hindsight analytics but as
you progress through the level you can
do foresight you can do Insight right so
this is evolving high level capability
based on like the micro tool level
tactical capabilities so you learn to
use the tools better and better and you
go from being reactive and hindsight to
predictive some some organizations
actually acquired capabilities this way
other people talked a lot about
analytics but didn't actually get there
here's another one these are all things
I pulled from Google Images so they're
real images that people presumably used
in some organizations this is an example
of security capabilities and this one is
interesting because it visualizes it as
growing capabilities on three vectors
technology process and people so the red
blue and green and each of them evolves
through multiple levels right so another
good
example you've probably heard a lot
about this one if you've been following
like the self-driving cars discourse
people talk about five levels of
autonomy what does it mean well little
bit bureaucratic little bit engineering
it's a mix of both it's technocratic
we'll have Sam doing a provocation later
on challenging the you know um ideology
of technocracy but there's a
technocratic model of what self-driving
should look like bureaucrats plus
engineers is putting it
together this one actually I just made
half an hour ago I was in a workshop
that I was running called Web of roots
and it was you know all about the
problems of crypto adoption and the uh
breakout session I was in was about how
there's a lack of tools in the ecosystem
and I made up this capability maturity
model so I have like five levels AI is
like a cloud around that so you can get
creative with this
stuff this one Tim do you want to
quickly speak to this vitalic road map
is kind of like uh uh CMM so Tim come
around speaking to the
mic oh okay oh we lost my slides okay um
yeah so in ethereum like vat was saying
we don't have a lot of LinkedIn CMM and
I think this is the closest we've come
to as an ecosystem uh to mapping things
out um and it's sort of like an implied
CMM here where if you think of the way
vitalic you know
um summarizes thisum world map um 2020
it was just like here's a bunch of stuff
we have to do in the next 10 years and
how they fit together um and not on this
slide is the 2019 version which is
here's a bunch of stuff scattered over
the Internet that we have to do in the
next 10 years um and it sort of like a
refinement and thinking over the years
where uh you know couple years after
that we were able to um actually break
this down in specific tracks so like the
merge Verge surge uh all all those
specific things um but still sort of
just like these like rough pointers that
we have that are quite low context um
and then just before Devcon and vitalic
actually put out a blog post for each of
these tracks sort of like going very
deep into details around like okay
what's the actual thing that needs to be
done where is it at what are the
blockers and what not and so you can see
that we have this sort of like evolving
capability um or at least falic has um
and then guiding the ecosystem to like
articulate or understand like what this
entire set of things we have to do is
and um how they all relate to each
other all right so now you have a bunch
of examples of CMM to refer to all these
are like real world ones so don't worry
too much about like what an abstract
definition of a CMM is keep these
examples in mind so how do you make a
CMM so one pick a specific important
Commons two pick a specific Target
social group that's trying to mature its
capabilities right so if you if the
commons you pick is like a lake and a
community around it that wants to keep
the lake ecosystem healthy the lake is
the commons and the people who are
trying to keep it healthy is the social
group try and Define four to seven
levels don't go over over seven keep it
actually close to four or five if you
want because it gets weird the
traditional ones are initial managed
defined Quantified optimized but feel
free to get totally creative name each
level and characterize it in terms of
people Technologies capabilities then
this one is very important number five
try and Define a test for each level so
if your CMM is about like you know
preserving a forest and you have a five
level hierarchy of how to preserve a
forest and say oh this um you know
Brazil is at level three but Indonesia
is at level two what the hell does it
mean Define a test for level two and
level three about how rainforest Commons
work okay um pick a visualization so I
gave you a few examples pyramids ramps
uh stacked blocks and stuff so pick a
good visualization if you don't like the
ones you have make one up but you know
this is not an art Workshop this is like
bureaucrat Workshop so you don't have to
get super artistic with it um think of
this whole CMM exercise as this is a
collective learning curve from like ad
hoc sort of like kind of illiterate
levels to very mature and refined
capabilities and it can go from like you
know very scattered skills like
everybody here uses web 3 wallets I
presume but there's like no coordination
it's like you know very fragmented but
if it matures presumably there'll be a
wide conversation about how which
wallets are better maybe they'll be
there already are but you know there's
not like textbook versions of the
discussion so collective learning curve
from ad hoc to uh mature from scattered
to integrated and usually there's an
element of codification and
documentation too in building a CMM and
both the organizational structure and
the people in it are learning as you go
along right forming procedural memories
so that even if people join and leave
the organization or system still
remembers right so if a whole bunch of
people create a CMM for something and
then half of them get new jobs and go
and a new half comes in the system
should not like break completely the
knowledge continuity should be there so
special challenges for us as kind of an
open uh ecosystem that's decentralized
in all these weird things so CMM are
typically for top- down traditional
organization where you know the CEO can
say hey I'm appointing a bunch of people
to impose this training program and all
of you are going to go from Level zero
to level five this is not that how do
you do it in an open ecosystem
context uh CMM rely on codification and
documentation in open systems that
typically happens in a much more ad hoc
way like maybe you know some volunteers
start documenting stuff um eips are a
good example where it's somehow jelled
into a very formal codification but not
in a corporate way uh CMM are usually
technocratic but can we actually not
make this about LinkedIn middle managers
and work with direct technological
agency and finally cmms often about
acquisition and installation of
behaviors in big corporations because
it's all theater the CEO wants to have
like a big program that they can brag
about once that happens and then the big
parties are done people forget and the
skills are not actually maintained so in
an open ecosystem actually the riverse
emphasis is better like it's better to
acquire and install a very limited
capability that then endures for 10
years than to like pretend that
everybody's level five black belt and
then like one year later nobody knows
how to log on to the system right so you
really should think in terms of
Maintenance of small
skills okay we're going to head into the
first breakout session so this is my
provocation okay so what is the bounding
box for your chosen Commons right so
what is the physical medium medium of
the common so if you're talking forests
it's like trees and grasslands and the
animals and the ecosystem if it's
software it's the git repository where
all your software lives so think of what
the actual physical material medium is
think about the neighbors of it right if
your code is on GitHub like ethereum's
code is one of your neighbors whether
you liked it or not is Microsoft because
Microsoft owns GitHub and so forth right
so think about your n uh neighbors what
is the nature of the boundaries and the
threat and exposure you have across
those boundaries so here's an example of
what I mean by a bounding box so treat
this as like strawman I don't
know if this is really any good but you
can think of like you know censorship
resistance ethereum development
processes these are the boundaries for
it the fact that the code lives on
GitHub that's a common not a threat but
a thing you have to think about right um
everything ethereum does is based on
compute and compute relies on chips and
chips come from tsmc and that's
vulnerable to conflict right Quantum
resistant cryptography another threat so
all these are like the bounding
conditions for what makes it possible
for ethereum to be healthy and just to
have a very different example if you
have a public Lake you have to think
about things like are there invasive
species what are the Environmental
regulations that are like constraining
what you do a really good example of
this came up in one of our sop research
projects last year where the people in
Brooklyn trying to preserve the
waterways they discovered that the local
regulations said that if the water is
being used for like human activities it
has to meet higher quality standards so
an activist group started canoeing in
the sewage contaminated canals of
Brooklyn and because of that they forced
by regulation The Regulators to actually
start cleaning up the canals right so
there's very interesting example of
stewarding the commons so
Lake okay so breakout number one so this
is the first one so first form groups of
three to five people so just where you
are look at your two nearest neighbors
bring your chairs a little closer
together and sop people I do not want to
see two sop people in the same group so
distribute yourselves accordingly um and
yeah together choose a Commons to work
on choose a Target population and maybe
draw a bounding box if it's useful and
then draw version one of this um you
know capability maturity model for your
common so set of named levels people
skills and so forth and test for the
abilities so we'll take 17 minutes to do
this starting now and I think Timber is
going to go around Distributing paper if
he hasn't already so form your groups of
three please three to four
you want to
come
we'll
e
e e
you
that
Jo
sh
[Music]
EX e
I
e
[Music]
e e
no
[Music]
sure
and
[Music]
I
the
GRE
[Music]
B
w
back
[Music]
just e
all right one minute left start W up
said
[Music]
continue discussing I'm to invite Sam up
here to give the second provocation onk
philosophy
Co all
right hello
hello okay uh this is going to be maybe
like 5 to 8 minutes just uh some
provocations on IDE of punk uh
disclaimer I'm not an expert on Punk
I've just thought a lot about it over
the past years I'm going to share some
maybe thought starters or frames that we
can use uh about
that so all right uh thinking about Punk
uh in the spirit of punk um looked a lot
at the genre of uh of punk cyber Punk
and others uh and the main theme that
emerges is the idea of the small versus
the system uh like the punk genre isn't
really like about saving the world it's
really about like this kind of
non-heroic uh anti-heroic uh character
about it if you think about something
like Blade Runner right you a lot of
people remember the world better than
they remember the the specific uh
characters uh and this is element of um
asymmetric conflict about uh about punk
where it's often this small Indie
protagonist versus big institutional
tagonist so there this kind of theme
around punk being uh the small versus
the
system uh and another angle on Punk is
the idea of like prep as the opposite of
punk right so uh you think of like a lot
of cultures there's these like I guess
prep schools or people who are brought
up for for greatness uh often insiders
and Elite uh School success very
institutional and then like a punk is
really often the protagonist are kind of
from very opposite kinds of uh stories
right they're like Outsiders every man
like uh what's destiny right you kind of
like you just grew up on the streets you
may be like a pizza pizza delivery guy
it's about a school of heart knocks and
you're very uh
alienated um and one of the visions of
punk is the idea of like uh can can that
be technology without the technocracy
right could we could all these new new
um tools that emerge uh if we have
systems to have a global digital
information system if we have ways of
like uh growing food could we have them
without the maybe accompanying systems
of of rule and order from above right so
a lot of the the genre of punk and the
spirit is really around exploring this
uh
possibility right so we can explore
think about the idea of governance uh
without governments uh and of course
ethereum is an example of like some
things that can be achieved uh Building
Technology without the kind of
traditionally we think about you need
big institutions and big order to really
be able to benefit from Big public goods
right but uh me the punk perod like if
you've seen some of the cyppher punk
stuff over the past couple days right
you that's a lot of the ambition to to
believe we can build uh big public stuff
without the same kind of institutional
top- down social order visions that
dominated much of the 20th
century uh and the last thing in the
bottom right corner is this uh kind of
almost like uh sort of cycle of how like
like
uh bad systems create a lot of punks
right so like when a system sucks
everyone ends up kind of being a deviant
in some ways uh and then like where
there more punks I guess like you go to
some maybe reform maybe Revolution and
then you try and build new institutions
and then if those like when you have
those then everybody wants to be part of
the system the system attracts a lot of
people to work in those institutions to
reinforce it but if you get complacent
you get thaten and then you get to that
cycle right so there this kind of cycle
that exists and do is so Punk isn't just
like about like uh so I'm approaching
this not just as like you want to make a
system of punks but also like what is
punk in a more systemic
context uh and I want to kind of share
like a few now systems level
perspectives of what what Punk is in a
broader kind of like a systemic view
right so part of the characteristic of
punk is that you're often aligned uh
according to the letter of the law but
not in the spirit of the law right so if
you think about look at 2 x two on the
side right you have the traditional
thing is that your either an outlaw you
don't like us you're not following the
the rules or you're a citizen you're an
Insight right but you can also have uh
you know like uh noobs who are basically
people who I kind of want to be a good
person I want to participate in this
community but I don't know the rules yet
right so I'm still learning and that's
kind of like a forgiving nature about we
can give you some time to onboard if
you're a kid you don't know what it's
like to you don't know the right way to
like like I don't know like use the
toilet right so we give you some great
period but then you have BS which is
kind of outside that typical framework
where like they know how to use the law
or the system they know the code really
well hackers knew really well how to
interface with these systems right but
they're subverting it for a different
Spirit right so like uh systems view
right like uh pun isn't Punk forces us
to think about Beyond just the idea of
ux Designing for the default users
you're trying to serve but also for like
uh what I can think of as exceptional
use cases right so how do you design for
the people who actually might repurpose
your system uh and do different things
uh with it uh and on the top right uh
the idea of affordances versus
instructions so like uh buks Embrace
technology in the sense of uh you you
give me like give me this new thing what
can I do with it show me how to do it so
like uh I can use this thing called the
internet what can I do with this how can
I build it but they resist this idea of
like uh give being directed or giving
being given direct instructions uh so
don't tell me what to do don't control
how I use this right and is this if I
zoom back and take a more ecological
view of this right uh the function that
punk is playing is really it's about
like uh emerging use um Evolution
adaptation if you think about in a
biological system right mutations happen
creativity happen uh happen so like uh
nutrients in a forest get repurposed
into different kinds of organisms they
create different kinds of things and
that's really important for the dynamism
of a particular uh system or ecology but
if you have too much of that then it
becomes dangerous right so we have this
kind of thing where uh there is a Cypher
Punk Spirit to this but if we want to
think about hardening a commment we have
to think also about like if you like if
you make it just for punks it kind of
blows up right so like how do you have
some sort of sense of like uh order
within there and like you almost have to
create something that's kind of balanced
and I want to leave uh you guys on this
idea of like uh like uh there almost a
spectrum of systems that more pun prone
where like just if you look at the
picture on the left right like clearly
this is a bad path right you're going to
everyone is going be not using it but
you could also Imagine a really Punk
proof system which is where like
everybody has to follow the default way
and that's no deviant at all and like uh
it might be tempting to think that
that's The Sweet Spot that's the
ultimate Harden commment right but or
maybe it's not because we actually for
this system to be able to grow and
Thrive going forward we need some sort
of space for for Mass for mutation for
Creative Evolution to occur right so
where's that sweet spot is it in the
middle is it on the right I think that's
something for us to explore in this
section so that's the provocation
thanks so this is the second breakout
think about what Sam just told you and
try to integrate Punk and hacker
elements of your Commons into your CMM
so it's weird it's like you know the the
man in incorporating like the subversive
element but I think if you don't try to
do that you kind of end up with
something fragile so revise and refine
the developing model you have to kind of
like reflect make your model Punk aware
think of it that way and by the way just
for your reference on that whiteboard I
put up all the commons that you guys
have chosen up there so I think it's air
water Wikipedia encryption schemes what
do we have internet memory Civic Norms
distributed intelligence and distributed
social media so wide variety of like
physical and digital systems so all
right another 17 minute breakout
continue working on your model add the
punk
element
[Music]
e
for for
[Music]
all
e for
[Music]
like for
actually
or
your
a
for
can
not
we consider
dat
St
every
not
all right one minute
all right do the third provocation and
then third break session
all right so the third provocation will
be by Josh Stark who came up with the
concept of hardness we've all been
talking about he'll give you a prompt
based on
that this is the clicker
cool okay hi everybody
um yeah I'm taller than Vates um okay so
let's run through this I want to start
with just kind of like a primer I want
to kind of give you a sense of oh thank
you
eblock don't think I did that oh
boy sorry
y'all okay so what kind of ideas
hardness I want to stop there and then
I'll dig into it a bit more so if you've
read the like thing I wrote about this a
couple years ago um I start with this
idea about the invention of of
information there's a great book called
the information that is about the
history of the concept information and
uh one of the things I learned from that
book is that it's actually a very recent
idea um if you you know like 200 years
ago at least in you know most places in
the west if you ask somebody like what
do what does a book and and a piece of
music and you know our language have in
common they wouldn't really be able to
articulate that that is you know kind of
a shared thing that all of those things
share this property called information
uh it really was not until this guy
Claud Shannon um who worked at Bell labs
in the 30s and 40s on lots of stuff uh
he was trying to solve various problems
um relating to I think at first like
military applications in like targeting
software used during the war um and then
in 48 he wrote a mathematical theory of
communication and this is the paper that
first coins the term the bit and he you
know kind of articulated very clearly a
you know a cons definition of the idea
of the bit and of information being a
thing that can exist in many different
mediums uh and he was using this for a
spefic purpose but this idea of
information as something that existed in
all these different forms and could that
we could apply a similar set of
principles and mathematical tools to
understand that information um that
really kind of took off and became what
we understand today uh it's very hard to
unthink ourselves out of our model
understanding of information because
it's just so obvious to us that it is in
all these things right so after he
publishes this paper um one of the
interesting that happened immediately
afterwards is uh Homer Jacobson who was
a a Prof in Hunter College in New York
City took these ideas and thought well
if you can measure the amount of
information that's used in these radio
transmission systems then I suppose I
could also measure the amount of
information that a human ear can like
you know process at time and then he
also wrote another p paper doing the
same thing for the human eye uh it was I
think at the time astonishing that this
thing that we were using to talk about
radio waves could also like equally be
applied in a useful way to biology and
of course DNA you know is information we
all understand that now and actually
some of the same ideas that Claud
Shannon invented um about like good
principles for um like a error in or
like a you know preventing errors
through like duplicative uh systems um
we actually find Evolution figured out
uh in terms of avoiding mistakes in how
DNA is replicated um so cool right so I
think that the idea of hardness is is
supposed to be kind of like that my my
pitch is that there is this property
called hardness that exists in a ton of
things that we all take for granted and
interact with all the time but we don't
really understand them as having a
uniform property and I got here
initially cuz I was just trying to
explain ethereum and blockchains to
people and the Insight I came to was
that it's not that we don't understand
blockchains is that we don't understand
everything else and so we don't have
this meta category to put them in that
would make sense of them so uh the pitch
is that these kind of three categories
of things all have hardness as a
property inside of them um so one
category is atoms right just the
physical stuff around us um we make
money out of just things we find in the
dirt right we picked up gold and over
time different civilizations learn that
there's not very much gold uh that it's
malleable that it's small enough and so
it became a very useful currency and so
that you know has been a thing and
continues to be a thing for a long time
many other cultures found other objects
in their ecosystems uh shells other
metals gems and these things just
happened to have these properties that
were durable right uh the amount of gold
available in your region of you know the
continent was not going to radically
change from one year to the next there's
this durable kind of Supply relationship
that makes this thing a useful money um
then later we invent institutions and we
use institutions to build all of the
things we call civilization right so
contracts and legislatures and police
forces uh this is another source of
hardness we can give an institution
instructions and trust that they will be
followed long into the future uh and you
know we also make money out of
Institutions um the money that we use
today is just really the property the
result of a whole bunch of people
coordinated in some organization that
follow rules and sets of behavior that
gives a certain stability to certain
properties of that money about its
Supply and you know tracking property
rights all that kind of stuff um and
lastly you know bit coin and ethereum
are another source of hardness they're a
new source of hardness that we also use
to make money and do many other things
we can do contract like things with
ethereum that really are a substitute
for the things that we use institutional
hardness for so that's the the big idea
that these things you know beneath the
hood like the reason we use we only use
these things to make money and the
reason that we only use at least
institutions and blockchains to make
these complex conditional relationships
over value is because they share a
property so that's the big idea um I
have a definition that I've used in
talks before uh and what I'm getting at
here is that hardness is like a
capability to just make something more
likely to be true in the future right we
can do this with institutions we can
give them instructions we can do this
with blockchains by giving them code um
and we have some like uh understanding
that it will be durable in the future it
is very likely to be certain in in the
future uh and it's certain enough that
we can kind of hang these other social
structures on them we can use it to be
money we can use it to organize a
government etc
etc so a few examples uh I talked about
gold already right uh atom hardness is
pretty good it has very very virtuous
properties it's the same everywhere the
rules of physics don't change depending
where you are but one weakness of them
is that as humans become more powerful
and have more capabilities things that
were hard stop being so hard right so if
we can go pull an asteroid full of gold
from somewhere else in the solar system
and bring it to Earth suddenly the
supply of gold which was a pretty hard
fact for a long time become soft and it
is no longer true that gold will
preserve its value in the same way um
there's the kind of famous case of of
zinga in Facebook where uh Zinga this
company that made games on the Facebook
platform form um was really reliant on
the institutional hardness of Facebook
uh to not you know totally just change
the way the terms of service worked and
change how the platform worked to you
know erode their business and and take
control of it um but this institutional
hardness was not very hard they were
just relying on the whims of this
company and it turns out that it wasn't
very trustworthy it wasn't didn't have
hardness um bottom left this is the
symbol for uh I think the like
International anarchic squatters
Association or something um the case of
squatting is interesting it's kind of
two things at once it is a way that
people exploit institutional hardness
you can think of squatters as like
institutional hardness hackers they're
kind of looking around the world for
where are property rights not actually
being enforced and we can set up camp
here and just see what happens and then
you discover that ah we thought there
was institutional hardness over these
property rights but there actually isn't
we can stay here uh and then of course
squatters also use institutional
hardness because in many places there
are such things as squatter squatter's
rights where if you live somewhere for
long enough uh the law says that now it
is yours and you can't be evicted um so
it's an interesting kind of edge case
that is uh punkish in in in the spirit
of the previous uh provocation and the
last one is of course an ethereum based
one um many of you might already know of
this artist uh
silent I just mispronounced his name um
he made this great piece of art uh a few
years ago called this work artwork is
always on sale and the idea is that it
uses ethereum to pre-commit that whoever
owns it anyone can always buy it by
meeting a certain price determined by a
harbit tax and so as an example of the
kind of commitment you can make to the
world using uh ethereum based hardness
that you couldn't really do otherwise
right I don't think there's really a way
that someone could legally set this up
in most places where you know whoever
owned it would always be forced to sell
it and transfer property that's not a
thing that our institutional Harden
systems are are ready set up for so I
think that's yeah that's all I got um so
that's the the big picture maybe vanes
will tell me if there's some big missing
piece that I should talk about in the
remaining seconds but if not I can sit
down all good okay
cool all right so let's do a quick
slightly structured uh prompt here so in
your group all of you privately think
about your chosen Commons and assess on
a scale of 1 to 10 how hard you think
your Commons is and how hard you think
it should be so for example if you think
your Commons is three out of 10 and
should be seven out of 10 so make up
those numbers and then in your group
share those numbers with each other
I will a
oh I'll do that in a second
all right before you guys get too into
it that was just kind of a warmup to get
you thinking about hardness in a hard
way uh but yeah let's actually take a
quick um maybe 5 minute break then come
back and we'll go straight into breakout
number three and actually talk about
this and try to integrate hardness into
your evolving CMM so 5 minute break come
back here we'll do the Breakout
she
[Music]
to
to e
[Music]
VAR
what
[Music]
f
there for
[Music]
years
all right we are back and we are into
break out number three so you should
start to converge a little bit by now so
by the end of this breakout session try
and have at least an initial list of
names for your levels short one or two
word names for your levels and um you
can put it up on the board when you're
ready you can edit it later but you
should have at least an initial list of
level names at the end of this breakout
so 15 minutes starting here
find
e e
few think
St e
somewhere
Comm
no e
we also need
St
ch
[Music]
said why
down
the
I
[Music]
was
the
like
that
that's
can't
ch f
all right
minut minute round
discuss e
all right we're ready for the next
provocation so Trent is going to be
talking about Commons and in next
breakout session I would like you guys
to start converging towards the set of
level name so please don't call your
five levels 1 2 3 4 five creative one or
two word names like this group is
talking about air maybe one of the
levels is you know aqi measured right
aqi measurements are available for
everybody that's a good name for a level
but all right over to Trend talking
about
Commons okay yeah so I'm Trent I work at
the ethereum foundation and I've been
working on protocol Guild for the past
few years and this will be kind of like
an applied example but we'll we'll talk
about enclosure
first
um this idea of enclosure uh I first
came across it about a year ago through
the work of this guy Benjamin burkenbine
he's a professor I don't remember the
school he's never responded to my emails
but uh really inspired by him um but
we've we're talking about Commons and
how they're peer produced resources uh
we talked about fisheries and forests um
these are naturally produced Commons and
uh I think what's important here is that
they are naturally occurring and then
humans engage with these systems which
would already typically produce them
maybe not farmland or pastures but
fisheries and forests these are
naturally occurring Commons when we get
to things like um the internet or
scientific data or software systems
these are
produced uh by humans deciding to do
them so they're
um it matters the production system that
um ultimately leads to these things as
the output and so when we talk about the
ethereum commons uh we are sometimes
talking about main net sometimes we're
talking about the software there's a
couple different things that are uh
wrapped up in here um but for the
software bit uh an example I come back
to quite often is this uh the Linux
ecosystem they have 30 years uh of
longer history than ethereum and there's
some instructive examples specifically
um the idea of uh what Benjamin
burkenbine calls incorporation uh the
incorporation of the commons and um so
he has his in this entire book on the
topic and the case study he he goes into
and I've written a little bit about it
is the idea of red hat uh which is a
company that works in the Linux
ecosystem and how their posture has
changed over time so they started in the
early days uh the early '90s uh had a
very good posture and by posture I just
mean like uh how they interact with
open- Source norms and engage with the
projects that make up this this software
Commons and so in the 90s had a really
great relationship with all of these
individuals and the teams and companies
that are working in Linux and over uh
decades at this point their relationship
changes the way way that they engage
with this open source software changes
they get acquired by IBM and all of the
sudden uh their mode switches from
contributing back to all of the sudden
they have these restrictions on how they
the licenses that the software was
released under and they start to break
the Norms that this community is
producing the software Rend and this
this gets into what I just mentioned
about like uh for Salmons it really
matters how it's produced because it
it's not naturally occurring uh there's
people have to actively um work on these
things and make sure that they you know
there's always bugs or they need to be
maintained over time so the production
system does really matter for
software and so for ethereum the these
three resource types that it produces
are the network the asset and the media
um the network is defined by protocols
whether it's the sync mechanisms PP
architectures um the fork choice there's
there's things that define how the this
resource is produced uh the same thing
for the asset this is another one of the
resources um ether can be put in a
number of different contexts um it's
defined by things like the proof of
stake issuance and the 1559 burn sorry
if this is unfamiliar but these are just
you know there's more of it or there's
less of it and there's rule sets that
are coded into the software that
explicitly defined how it goes up and
down uh and we're going to specifically
narrow into this this media bit
um because this is this is the
production system that these other two
depend on right there's software which
defines how the network acts the the way
that peers send data to each other uh
the the software defines also how the
asset acts and how it interacts with the
network because it's it's an incentive
for validators to participate in
consensus so all of these three things
are interwoven in some way and then they
produce this thing that we we call
ethereum Main net
um right so the these are the the common
resources and they are produced by today
a a pretty wide variety of entities
these are both commercial for-profit and
and nonprofit and they all take up a
different slice of the main net Commons
um and they all have their own interests
their own uh Tendencies towards
extraction or enclosure whatever term
you want to use they have incentives so
for
example uh Paradigm is a venture capital
company their goal is to make money for
their LPS or you know the The Entity
itself most of the time I'd say 99% of
the time or maybe all of the time this
interest is coincident or moving in the
same direction as what the commons needs
or what the ethereum what is best for
the ethereum protocol and the people
that use it uh the companies that build
on top of it um but there may be a case
in the future where a venture capital
company uh engages with this this set of
main net contributors or let's say they
purchase a company you know if it's if
it's for sale somebody might be
interested Google shows up with $20
million and says look I want to engage
in this production this system of
production that's maintaining this
software and uh get some sort of
political benefit um because ultimately
um because ultimately um this is Commons
is they're not just people showing up uh
day after day and it's released again
this is this is an open- Source software
Commons it's released without uh
restrictions on how you can use it this
is kind of a a core component about um
how this thing actually works and the
guarantees that it has so you can't
necessarily make a claim on the output
but what you can make a claim on is the
the production process and the way that
you get exposure to that production
process is by um you know becoming
active or or having a voice and so
um these for-profit entities they may
have external incentives to pull out
from the commons uh but you can also
Imagine uh a nonprofit found uh entity
like the ethereum foundation is there in
the middle bottom um
let's imagine an evil version of the EF
they want to dominate and take control
of this uh you know this system of
production and they want to pull
themselves into it and it's crucial that
um the constituent entities don't
necessarily gain too much control right
it's it's good that there are many
different kinds of organizations and
many different entities that are able to
engage in this process it's open it's
public and um anybody can can
participate in it uh whether their their
incentives are to pull out or to pull in
and dominate um there is it's important
to just be aware of these Tendencies and
uh have mechanisms that maybe constrain
uh the Tendencies of these different
kinds of organizations so what protocol
Guild
does um it's a if you're not familiar
with it it's a a collective funding
mechanism for all of these individuals
who are working on the software and it
composes a higher level abstraction to
um approximate the edge of the commons
or the shape of the the software
commment all of these little bits of
software the teams and individuals that
work on this uh again they have their
own incentives their own
Tendencies um the the the own their own
legal structures which contain
individuals so what protocol Guild does
is it uh combines them all together on
the level of the individual and makes
them more legible on the scale of the
commons and this does some things um so
imagine Google shows up it's a lot
easier to buy one of these tiny little
boxes than it is this this large
protocol Guild shaped object so you you
return some of the agency you can think
of it either to the
individuals uh because you materialize
them as part of this larger Collective
abstraction which is all of the sudden
you uh represent it at this this higher
level
scale and so when you have this
abstraction then you can start to do
interesting things with it you can send
funding to it um whereas when all of
these entities or the projects within
them are um embedded within a number of
different
organizations with uh again different
incentives different payment struct
suddenly you have this this very legible
like this this exists on chain as an
organization that splits funding
directly to all of these individuals uh
you can fund it um if you want to think
of this as like a core core contributor
Ubi if that's useful to you um we send
funding to the median contributor and
they get US dollars to sustain their
work uh alternatively we also provide
ecosystem exposure to these individuals
because one of the challenges with open
source software is especially in the
crypto industry is that you don't have
exposure to um the the the promise of
venture capital funded projects like
it's you're never going to be able to
match the the the massive pool of
capital that's swirling around the edges
on the outside but what we can do is
start to provide some uh material
Financial benefits for people who are
still doing this important work and so
you're able to rebalance a little bit of
the incentives to resist what might
otherwise be this pull outwards to
extract uh and avoid enclosure
um so that's like the money aspect uh
but there's more subtle things this is a
solidarity mechanism that only uh comes
from the output of uh people cooperating
together and recognizing that yes they
may be an employee or a member of a
for-profit or nonprofit but what they
really are a part of is this larger
scale Commons
construction um and and I could probably
do a much more refined version of this
but then you start to think about okay
we can provide these carrots to people
to participate in this uh this higher
level abstraction which is the financial
benefits uh but the the Ostrum
definition would start to think about
okay what are the penalties for
defection I mean there's we can't really
enforce a penalty because again the
output of this uh Commons or commoning
process is free the software is free for
anybody to use already so we can't cut
off anybody's access but what we can do
is provide these positive incentives to
make sure um the you know
the level of workmanship the kinds of
ideals that are being baked into the
software we can have common
standards uh uh I should probably choose
a different term than common standards
but shared shared realities for what
kind of value should this soft Ware um
this this software embody and that's
where the guild term is really
descriptive because you know guilds were
important in the Middle Ages for setting
these standards and uh we imagine that
this is a useful U mechanism for U
championing credible neutrality for uh
ensuring that the software of the
ethereum commons is credibly neutral
these kinds of things
um yeah and then and then the related to
hardness I think the one thing that you
can do with these um larger funding
mechanisms relative to uh enclosure and
where funding is coming in and out of a
Commons is that you can start to
distribute funding over time um whereas
somebody might get fired or you know
made redundant all of a sudden they have
this external um source of funding that
is not necessarily tied to the you know
the movements of markets and things like
that so you can start to layer in a ton
of different things when you um make
these individuals legible outside of
their immediate employment context and
on the scale of the the broader Commons
itself so
yeah okay so we are now getting into the
meat of it so next 17-minute breakout
session think about these questions
what are the enclosure and capture
Dynamics psychology of the people both
inside and outside like you identified a
Target group of stewards in the first
breakout but they all are not
necessarily aligned some of them might
defect and become the threats right so
think about what Trent just said and
like think about you know mechanisms
like the protocol Guild that can Harden
against those um uh challenges right so
17 minutes but at the end of this
breakout send one representative from
your group over to those white boards
there's like nine columns there you
should have your list of level names
identified maybe you can later edit them
5 to seven at most and put them down
there right so at the end of this
breakout that those three whiteboards
should be full so 17 minutes go
gu
have
ch
want
SOA
always
you
a little Bond
Francisco you you
think
was comp
so
m
it's just question
problem
SI
do
[Applause]
so that'll be the next
you have
but it's
like solve the problem
the
still
you want like in the shape of the
pyramid
should
ask
honestly I think
how
come
are my
a
EX
all right couple more minutes then we'll
go to the lastation so finish writing up
your
white last
I me
Bri
back
all right we're going to go into the
last provocation please go back to your
seats you can finish up
later back from the
whiteboards all right Tim's going to
like now set you the hardest provocation
connecting this all up to
ethereum hi everyone who hears not in
summer of protocols raise your hand W
thank you for staying the full three
hours um so far um yeah so this is
ethereum Devcon so we're going to
sprinkle a little bit of ethereum and
all of this um so Josh uh talked about
hardness uh right before we talk a bit
related to this yesterday but in short
there's a few things that are like
special about ethereum's hardness first
is that it's globally homogeneous anyone
in the world that accesses ethereum has
the same experience very different from
institutions or atoms um independently
hitable so all the chain data is public
which you can just go and look at again
different from uh other forms of
hardness and then permission to see
accessible meaning that there's just
like a very low barrier to entry right
like you could just plug in your
computer and use it but one thing e
theum uh sort of does not do quite well
is having a view of the outside world uh
in crypto we call this the Oracle
problem
um but the like non-technical definition
of this is that if you want to put a
fact about the world on ethereum you
need to have a mechanism and then that
mechanism is not as hard as ethereum
itself and so um I want to dive a bit
deeper into like where ethereum hardness
works and like where the challenges are
and then um how that can potentially be
applied to um these vast diverse uh
Commons that we've been looking yet um
so the first very obvious one ethereum
as a blockchain provides a Harden found
for applications and assets and
protocols to be built on top of it um so
if you put something on ethereum you can
have an expectation that you know it
will stay on the chain that it will
function in the way that you've
programmed it on chain um and you know
we see this in practice there's billions
of assets uh issued on ethereum but
there's also things like you know
cultural artifacts like say nfts um
where um you know the fact that the
chain can preserve uh the nft itself is
a valuable
property but then there's another part
about at ethereum community that uh
relates to hardness and uh vat mentioned
this at the very beginning there's sort
of these two definitions of hardness the
definition around like um sort of Josh's
framing around longevity but the
definition second definition is more
around like battle testing thing or like
resistance to external shocks um and
ethereum's culture sort of mixes both in
an interesting way like um both at the
protocol level at the application Level
um we have all of we we operate in like
a very adversarial environment um we
have all these hacks that happen or
attacks and we sort of of built these
systems and processes and Norms to
mitigate or respond to them in an
efficient way and then at the cultural
level you know ethereum has this uh set
of values around trying to optimize for
the long term move the focus away from a
single institution not have like a
central point of failure in the
ecosystem and also have a technical road
map that's long-term sustainable so
that's like a softer way to like export
ethereum's hardness into other
domains and so um you know putting those
things together a couple examples that I
again mentioned yesterday uh in the talk
but um that we've seen in practice where
like ethereum's been kind of good to
integrate with things outside of it and
and have like this positive feedback
loop the first um is this idea around
quadratic voling quadratic funding so
was this new uh allocation mechanism
that was sort of theorized uh in
Academia um that didn't really have a
good place to be deployed because um
existing institutions tend to be more
risk averse when they're allocating
funds so we were able to deploy this on
ethereum um initially on gitcoin run a
bunch of Grants and learn from that
process about okay what works what's
broken with the mechanism tweak the
mechanism and then sort of improve the
theory back and there's like a positive
feedback loop there where ethereum is
kind of the test bed for this and we can
bring it uh we can test things in like
this isolated environment um and then
scale them up to a size that's like
relevant for the outside
world and then another similar example
is prediction market so again this is
this theoretical idea
that um didn't quite have a place to get
prototyped uh got some early prototyping
done on ethereum augur was I think the
first version of this um or maybe the
second um even though auger itself
wasn't quite successful um the idea and
sort of being on ethereum and seeing it
live inspired others which eventually
led to poly market and then we can see
you know polym Market played a major
role in the current US
election and so you can think of this as
like a V diagram of things that uh
leverage ethereum's technical hardness
things that leverage the cultural
hardness and potentially there's like
some intersection in between um that are
uh things that are not necessarily built
on ethereum directly but that can either
um learn from it or do things on it but
then have an impact in a broader world
and I think that's like a useful frame
to to use when you're when you're trying
to think of like okay how can ethereum
actually help you know something that's
not an app on chain um and so this will
be like my prompt basically um how can
ethereums either their sorry how can e
ethereum's technical capabilities or
sort of cultural hardness can can uh how
can that improve your CMM um and one
thing I would like encourage you to do
is like think are there alternative
sources of hardness you could use rather
than ethereum and like why is ethereum
the right one and maybe ethereum is not
the right one and that's fine and you'll
learn something but um if if it is right
like it's worth thinking like okay why
can't the government do do this why
can't you know gold do this or something
like
that and similarly though if you are
thinking about like a way that this can
leverage ethereum um I would think
through how can people bypass this it's
just back to like this Oracle problem um
you know if you have something where
you're saying um we're going to monitor
everybody's going to like put something
on the blockchain to monitor that like
the air quality is good to take my
example um how do you make sure that the
people putting the air quality numbers
on the blockchain are putting the real
air quality numbers and not just you
know making something to get a
reward and um and then yeah I think the
third thing is kind of going back to
this poly market and get quite example
is there some sort of positive feedback
loop where like if you experiment and
learn things by like using ethereum um
you can then push this back into the
real world or and then you know
potentially bring the bigger version on
ethereum and so on and so and it's like
the last part that uh or sorry the last
iteration that we'll be doing on a model
so um yeah take all of this try to apply
it to the model and we will do a share
back session after this in 17 minutes
[Applause]
thanks s remember it's my 50th birthday
and this is your birthday gift to me so
I
want I want two very clean sheets like
one two Max sheets with your complete
model and like as cleaned up form as you
can make it that'll be what we take a
picture of and you know publish right
I'm sure you guys have like a lot of
messy working notes let's make this
breakout a little longer so like uh 25
minutes think about temp's prompts about
uh ethereum but also like clean up your
model and capture it in one or two paper
sheets of paper all right
paper paper paper
cap
AR you saw that big building
like
that was
than
this
privac
to used
whatever what
that's
why we also need to
has to be
do
all
when they come over take
you e
say
this is prob
think
f
all right guys 8 minute warning and a
point
us
start
of
that's
some
they
off
AA forming nice terraforming
one minute warning
now
rep
bring it back
in
So yeah thank you all first of all for
like persevering through three hours to
do this exercise I know it's like not
the easiest kind of thinking to do like
it's that mid level of abstraction that
can be really annoying especially late
in the afternoon uh but yeah thank you
all for p pers heing and we have nine
very interesting lists of phrases here
so after we done with the share backs as
you're all heading out do take a moment
to just walk past and like look at each
of them and maybe take pictures for your
future reflection but now let's get into
the share back session and I just um
slightly tweaked um the suggested
outline so take about maybe three
minutes for each group send up one
representative here to speak into the
mic so we have a proper live stream
recording so Point your whiteboard list
and just read out your levels so people
have a sense of like the you know motifs
you're going for um maybe talk about one
thing that was really hard in the
exercise because this is good research
input for us we want to know like what's
hard and what to try and make easier and
then maybe one good Insight that came
out of um your process but otherwise
yeah free format so if there are no
volunteers I'm just going to pick
randomly any group want to go
first all right Trent sorry was the
first I have it up there yeah come up
here and speak into the mic that way
it'll
be well just I really just wanted to say
the one Insight but I guess I'll do all
of them
um all right so the levels so we were
talking about air and the levels we had
um specifically thinking of Bangkok and
Thailand broadly first level is air
Anarchy there's polluters bad emissions
no systems of measurement visible smog
Smoky season in the north uh and then
the punk is like ECOT terrorism of
people you know taking direct action
against the production of this this poor
air
quality
um the second one is air awareness so we
we imagined you'd start to understand it
through data start a process of
localized data collection um understand
the scope of the problem ways to
mitigate it um punk would be the
organized protest ways of surfacing
visibility to this
issue
um third air assessment regulations on
uh ideal parts per million goal setting
U maybe you have DIY air measurement
distributed pollution
monitoring uh four is air actuation
that was not very good incentives and
sanctions you can start to think about
Regional Regional commitments because
obviously you have your local context
but there's also it's a it's a good that
moves across borders and doesn't really
care for them
um incentives and sanctions commitments
to targets policy
accountability uh or like the re the ROI
on the policy that you're implementing
and then the last one was
um AA forming or air augmented but yeah
so this could be like building the
actual infra and um making sure that you
have systems to to produce clean air uh
maybe people are getting their um daily
vitamin intake through this this
augmented air um we don't really have a
system for implementing that but it it
sounds
interesting
um one thing that was hard
do you guys what was hard I don't
know coming up with tests for each level
all right we'll go with that uh the main
thing I just wanted to talk about was
during the the capture bit I guess this
is mostly relevant to me but we were
thinking about how defining the scope of
the problem and the people that are
tasked with fixing
it there needs to be some sort of bounds
on the definition otherwise you end up
with this
Perpetual um you know you know similar
to like the philanthropy or charity
industry there's a vested interest for
the people that are Distributing Aid to
continue these uh Distribution Systems
regardless of whether there's more
efficient or more
um uh yeah systems that are that are
just better at DIS Distributing funds or
resources to people there there's a
vested interest in keeping them the way
that they are because people get paid
through it so that was one thing that we
uh was kind of an interesting bit about
like okay how do you define the scope of
this problem what what does it mean to
solve it um because at a certain point
there will be uh the people that end up
um engaging with the production of a
solution you don't want it to get
entrenched as the
um the new uh status quo even when it
you know there's Improvement on it and
maybe there's perverse incentive to to
maintain this over time that's
it since it's 612 we have to be like
mindful of time so 3 minutes exactly I
will time all of you guys let's just go
order by yeah three minutes
go all right everyone my name is Daniel
our topic was speciic Norms which we
were kind of proud of as like kind of a
a clever idea of culture itself as a
resource so that we ended up just kind
of rediscovering kind of a whole
sociological theory of History so that
was kind of funny but um our kind of
phases were something kind of like the
king you know no real structure very top
down power driven then we had the tribe
where we have kind of simple notion of
order kind of like a Ten Commandments
Society um very kind of Shame High
control and then something like the
state development of more institutions a
bit more personal freedom a bit more
regular a bit more sophisticated law
system and then the culture which was
sort of the um somewhat solar Punk
Collective Enlightenment restorative
justice um internal motivation all
around and then the last one we couldn't
quite articulate so we just kind of
called it the great Cosmic M which was a
Nazi sit
artha um something that was hard was you
know as we kept going through all these
different phases and we kept kind of
complexifying the model you know we kept
trying to you know abstract and shoehorn
things in and some things didn't quite
fit and we tried and just acknowledging
that you know this doesn't quite fit in
the model that's as fun as it is like we
got to drop this that was a bit of a
hard conversation to have sometimes and
um one thing that was one Insight was
you know once we kind of worked out the
the framework everything really fell
into place in kind of a beautiful way
like every cell kind of got really easy
to fill in once we knew what we were
doing and that was a real that was
actually really quite Pleasant to have
it all kind of locked into place like
that so that was kind of nice to
experience
[Applause]
hi everyone uh my name is harith uh so
our topic was encryption schemes and um
I'll start with the one thing that was
hard was that uh our one teammate that
suggested this topic uh who actually
knew more about the subject had to leave
halfway so
so the main learning was maybe to get
enough team members to know what they're
talking about um when it comes to a
particular topic uh so for our levels uh
the first one is uh we describe it as uh
Wilderness um so for encryption schemes
where there's only academic research and
there's minimal distribution uh of the
research on the subject then the second
level is managed where there are now
developer ecosystems that have formed um
in the real life example is uh say psse
in etherum foundation and others that
are working towards um kind of creating
their own ecosystems for this then the
next level the third level is irrigated
where there are now open source
libraries or licenses and there's
documentations on uh established ux
patterns uh for this uh
encryptions the fourth level is
monitored where there are agreed upon uh
standards for incentivizing uh
researchers whether that's in bounties
or having some sort of retroactive
public goods funding uh for uh
disclosing
vulnerabilities and the last level is uh
thriving where there are now automated
economic mechanisms to uh sustain uh
maintenance uh of these researchers and
um the research that they're
doing uh one big insight about the
process was that um at least for this
topic it's multidimens ition uh so there
are like potentially governments that
are trying to like forbid access to uh
this kind of research uh there's
corporations who might want to kind of
co-opt it and like create patents and
own uh all this stuff uh and there's
like developer burnout how do you make
sure that these developers can keep on
being incentivized and sustained so that
they can keep doing the best work for
everyone uh that's pretty much it for us
thanks
okay so we did uh Wikipedia as a kind of
knowledge
Commons um for our our levels level one
we call gibberish which is just
unverified and
unorganized level two is a what we call
propaganda which is organized but very
biased level three uh we called Academia
which is manually verified but kind of
closed and gate kept not not open to
everybody uh level four was open source
which is um transparent and verified and
then we have uh the final one was Oracle
with an asterisk um and this is uh we
have some kind of attest station system
it's Dynamic auditable and
transparent uh one thing that was hard I
mean honestly we kind of we kind of just
knocked this out of the park right away
so um I'm just kidding I think uh what
was hard uh we had a good discussion
about um on the punk access axis um
total anonymity versus total
transparency what's the right what's the
right level of anonymity versus
transparency and how to na navigate that
uh one big Insight um I guess I'll just
share one thing I observed is that U we
can think of naming things as a way of
closing them down or finishing them but
I actually found that um naming things
is a good way of iterating things
because the the name never actually
quite gets it right so when you name it
you can kind of go oh that's that's
pretty good but then there's usually
another name behind it and I thought
that was pretty interesting
[Applause]
so we did evacuation
routes and
evacuation
routes uh number one was dirt roads so
just um yeah not not on a map or
anything just a a route number two was
making it onto a map so that there's a
collective reference for where the road
is three was paved and serviced um so
actually maintained kept free of
potholes um and uh participation of a
municipality
four was evacuation status recognition
so kind of like elevated to the special
uh recognition that it's essential and
so this comes with like daily servicing
with the
plow five was Community
convergence um and with conver
convergence was also conversion so the
community is now are now active
participants in the maintenance of the
road um which leads into six of just
redundancy planning making sure that you
don't have one um response plann for
what to do in an
emergency and seven was enclosure
strategies is we started to respond to
like potential corporate use and overuse
of the road how do you make sure that
you're defended against um yeah those
potential um kind of interruptions to
evacuation
and what was
hard I would say navigating like these
kind of two layers of um actors so on
one hand there's the municipality and
then on the other there's uh the
neighborhood and the people who actually
um in the case of an emergency are
responsible for maintaining the road um
so like yeah knowing how to be dynamic
between those two actors and how to
layer them on top of each other um
governance and the actual like practical
use and um some insights are that
Commons arise when governments don't act
or fail to act
enough
um
and yeah we were curious
around using ethereum for like
recognition of Labor and when people are
doing so much work that is uh hidden
whether it's like removing a tree from
the road or um fixing some aspect of it
that they're be a shared source that is
able to compensate those people and um
kind of like direct uh Commons
fund thank you
uh yeah ours was uh internet's memory uh
it was going well until somebody from
the internet archive showed up
so
um so yeah so um the uh the four faces
we have is the first is uh UND
Discerning centralized storage so
essentially what you have now with
internet archive where you can upload
like save things but um the governance
is pretty centralized and also uh you
know the government can censor it uh the
second one uh the second stage we have
is uh sufficiently decentralized storage
uh so in this case the governance is uh
Central we call it centralized fuzzy
governance it's still not fully
decentralized but maybe the storage is
much more uh decentralized uh maybe
there are uh it expands into multiple
locations in multiple continents uh so
that it's not easy to censor um and the
test for this uh stage is is it always
accessible so that's the question um
that should be answered and uh the third
stage is U capture assistant utility uh
so at this stage we want um a more uh of
like basically a moderately
decentralized garance incentives for
maintaining incentives for our ariving
and maintenance um um and um the
question that we want answered here is
like is there rough consensus on how
this is run uh so U yeah that's
basically the sort of third part and
um the fourth one is yeah so uh we call
it indispensable utility so at this
stage um people should be able to Fork
multiple instances of the same thing and
there should be like standards uh for
foring these instances and so uh
standards adoption becomes a thing there
um and also uh solving really hard
problems like basically we uh realized
once AR who works at internet archive
came in there were sort of like basic
issues that we sort of forget that are
pretty hard such as like d duplication
uh which is uh which he mentioned is
something that has not been solved yet
so those are sort of basic things we
only considered at the fourth stage uh
but um so I think that was maybe one of
the hard things about doing this was um
yeah like sometimes there are like
things that you sort of take for granted
that end up being extremely uh have
extreme complexity um and uh yeah and
for the four stage the question we are
asking is uh is there standards adoption
for it to become an indispensable
utility um and yeah uh um yeah what was
hard I think was um it's such a broad
thing like internet memory so maybe uh
narrowing it down more would have helped
uh but also when you the bounding boxes
like you run into so many other systems
that have their own complexity such as
like like state law and stuff that is
its own uh like systemic complexity that
is like hard to grock so uh I think um
yeah like so it becomes hard once you
like start asking a couple more
questions there
um but uh yeah so that's it from us
thank you
right so the comment that we ended up
choosing was uh decentralized AI of how
exactly can uh Commons based on AI
actually be developed and then Sim
successively governed now we ended up
our CMM ended up taking the form of a
you can say a
chronological Evolution model you can
see that torpedo over there it's
supposed to be a pyramid but you know if
you squint just right enough it looks
like a pyramid um so the level one is
the birthing stage and this is where any
talk of decentralized AI is currently
and that's largely just regular open-
sourced AI that you see Curr you see
currently stuff like llama you know it's
been sort of uh it's all contingent upon
the benevolence of a specific
centralized entity like in the case of
llama it's Facebook sure you have people
using the license to work on llama but
still largely centralized sorry for yeah
I was touching the keyboard I did not
realize that uh the second stage is the
community capacity building stage now
the community capacity building stage
when it comes to Common governance it
should ideally follow the principles of
progressive decentralization so there's
small aspects that you entrust to the
Community First and then you follow it
up with more important decisions um
ideally this stage culminates with the
exit to community stage where the
centralized intermediary which birthed
the project no longer has any control or
say over how it proceeds next up we have
the curation stage so this is where the
community working groups hopefully of
now there are many because of exit to
community they are actively developing
improving and deploying this resource
the resource being the decentralized AI
the end result of this uh stage is the
development of various use cases that
daai can be used for Integrations that
it can be deployed with users whose
needs it can actually sort of cater to
and next up is the value generation
stage this is not exactly a final stage
because the curation and value
generation stage uh keep on shifting
back and forth uh the value generation
stage is where basically this Commons
can actually be
independently it can have an independent
life of its own
through money right so it basically
involves the creation of monetization
strategies which are not contingent on
uh on intermediaries and the creation of
a common treasury which is held in
common trust and go accordingly you know
ideally by stuff such as quadratic
funding mechanisms now going across each
stage requires various cultural shifts
we' also come up with a list of several
different cryptoeconomic Primitives on
ethereum which can suffice to uh um
govern um decentralized AI I'll just
list them very quickly won't describe
them one stake based shelling game
mechanisms two a Marketplace for compute
three civil resistant tokenized
governance mechanisms four quadratic
funding pools and five zkl tools now
that being said what was hard about this
project well just getting started was
hard I think our entire first 20 minutes
was just us staring at each other and
not knowing what to do what actually to
write down but once we got over that
stage I think I had a lot of fun and you
know I had I I had a great time talking
to my team this is a contribution from
all my team so they all uh deserve a
round of applause for this and you know
if you had more time I think we could
have come up with a great proposal for
decentralizing AI which we could then
pitch to investors and make a lot of
money hopefully but thanks a lot
so we did a water
reservoir and the first layer was fully
vulnerable slopen SL Anarchy
um so no institutional
hardness second one was stewarded by one
group so one sort of institution decides
to take care of the
reservoir um
and uh so that would be a allow medium
Punk medium hard uh kind of yeah
openness and then the third level would
be governed uh so with some cultural
expectation around um how the reservoir
should be
managed um and um yeah having some level
of policy basically policy and culture
around it the fourth level we call
networked pluralist um which would have
many overlapping
structures um managing the reservoir
and
um yeah and then we we made a comment
about hardness being different from
rigidity
rigidity uh and I think something
difficult in the activity was that we
were dealing with the natural resource
type of thing that was very specific so
we were not talking about just water as
a whole we're talking about water
reservoir and yeah it was difficult to
apply some of the Frameworks to that
um and yeah just the difference in the
vocabulary also uh of the challenges
with ethereum in comparison to that
[Applause]
hello my group handled uh decentralized
social media um and we split this into
stages based on the size of
um the number of people that the social
media could support um so we have uh
friends which you need like peer-to-peer
uh connectivity uh basically a group
chat um you need to be able to do
boundary definition and have like uh
like an an immediacy to um the the user
experience um we've got neighbors uh
where you start to need distributed
storage and uh identity sovereignty um
you need some form of
administration um and then
discoverability um so that you can
navigate the network um we have
strangers within a shared culture um and
here you start to need uh composable uh
privacy and anonymity um and Federated
uh domains of of administration um as
well as filtering as you start to need
to to uh adjust the content that you're
seeing based on your uh your
sphere then we have uh strangers within
different cultures um and we start to
need sharding for the uh amount of
information that you're storing um
reputation plural governance um and uh
concentrated efforts at at accessibility
so languages and and other methods of
providing access um and then finally we
have all beings um so a theoretical
version of social media in which it
encompass is all forms of human
Communication online um so we have human
right uh access to the network is
ensured as uh human right Network
sovereignty the the network itself is is
completely self- Sovereign and uh
multiplanetary
connectivity um I think the biggest
challenge in this was determining what
our like success criteria was like how
we defined hardness because there's a
lot of ways to Define hardness for this
particular subject area um um and I
think that we settled on the number of
people just
because social media becomes stickier
and like more entrenched by the number
of people that are using it um which
makes it harder as a
system thank
you all right a few seconds over so is
the end of the session thank you all for
coming remember to take photographs and
hand your sheets of paper to Timber here
and please please look at the white
boards on your way out all right thanks
a lot
[Music]